in spite of the steady accumulation of
detailed knowledge
how the human brain works is still
profoundly mysterious
[Music]
the ultimate goal of neuroscience is to
learn how the brain gives rise to human
intelligence
and what it means to be intelligent
understanding how the brain works is
considered one of humanity's greatest
challenges
i got into this field because i just was
curious as to who i am
you know how you know how do i think
what's going on in my head when i'm what
i'm thinking what does it mean to know
something you know i can ask what it
means for me to know something
independent of how i learned it from you
or from someone else or from society
what does it mean for me to know that i
have a model of you in my head what does
it mean to know i know what this
microphone does and how it works
physically even when i can't see it
right now
how do i know that
what does it mean how do the neurons do
that at the fundamental level of neurons
and synapses and so on those are really
fascinating questions the neuroscientist
francis crick observed that scientists
have been collecting data on the brain
for decades they knew a lot about the
workings of the brain but they hadn't
converged on any meaningful theory of
how the brain worked how intelligence
emerges from low level cells in your
head is still a profound mystery
to be intelligent the brain has to learn
a great many things about the world
to understand how the brain creates
intelligence we need to figure out how
the brain learns a model of the world
and everything in it
jeff hawkins thinks that the reality we
perceive is a kind of simulation a
hallucination a confabulation
he thinks that our brains are a model of
reality based on thousands of
information streams originating in the
senses in our body critically hawkins
doesn't think that there's only one
model but rather
thousands jeff has just released his new
book a thousand brains a theory of
intelligence it's an inspiring and well
written book and i really hope after
watching this show you'll be inspired to
read it too
now jeff is a sub symbolist he thinks
that our knowledge is sliced and
distributed over the substrate of
synapses in our brain but similarly that
our simulated models of the world are
also distributed over hundreds and
thousands of cortical columns this means
that when we recognize a dog there's a
society of cortical columns all
independently predicting that the dog is
there and mutually calibrating after a
consensus is reached
now jeff hawkins is a materialist he
thinks that despite appearances to the
contrary mental states are just physical
states and that the latter emerges from
the former there's no inception
no ghost in the machine
no
cartesian theater if i had to
summarize into one
big idea
is that we think of the the brain the
neocortex is learning this model of the
world but what we learned is actually
there's
tens of thousands of independent
modeling systems going on and so each
what we call a column in the cortex is
about 150 000 of them is a complete
modeling system
so
it's a collective intelligence in your
head in some sense so the thousand
brains theory says well where do i have
knowledge about you know this coffee cup
where is the model of this cell phone
it's not in one place it's in thousands
of separate models that are
complementary and they communicate with
each other through voting hawkins says
that the neocortex is the outermost and
most recently evolved layer of the
mammalian brain a bit like a wrinkly
napkin
which wraps around the old brain it
occupies about 70 percent of the volume
of your brain and it's responsible for
all aspects of your intelligence that is
to say your sense of vision
touch
hearing language in all its forms and
even abstract thinking such as
mathematics and philosophy
the neocortex is surprisingly different
to other parts of the brain it has no
visually obvious divisions the
anatomical organization is strikingly
similar
nevertheless different parts of the
neocortex still perform different
functions like vision or hearing for
example the complex circuitry of the
neocortex looks remarkably alike in
visual regions and language regions and
even touch regions
it looks similar across species such as
rats cats and humans the variations
between regions are relatively small
compared to their similarities
now hawkins argues that the complexity
of the brain is in the content of its
connections and its wiring which is an
emergent property of a simple learning
algorithm i mean look at the openai
microscope their tool for visualizing
trained convolutional neural networks as
an example the learning algorithm is
simple but all of this beautiful
complexity emerges as a result of
training
even after this type of visualization
it's not really understandable by us
humans
it's possible that any successful
knowledge representational substrate for
some domains of data may never be
understandable by humans
now the neocortex is arguably one of the
main organs of intelligence it gives us
sensory perception
motor control and abstract thought
the key attributes it has are its
ability to learn continuously learn
rapidly its power efficiency and its
flexibility which is to say its ability
to learn diverse and novel tasks
now hawkins argues that the neocortex
learns a model of the world that each
cortical column is a complete sensory
motor modeling system he thinks that
cortical columns use reference frames to
store knowledge and generate behavior
our brains learn about the outside world
by processing our sensory inputs and
movements the neocortex anticipates the
sensory results of movement when we
touch objects or observe the world
around us our brain receives a sensory
motor sequence of information
when moving our fingers over familiar
objects we quickly notice discrepancies
suggesting we make tactile predictions
that are specific to particular objects
hawkins believes that the prediction of
sensory stimuli after movements is the
fundamental primitive of cognition the
brain does not just memorize the sensory
information as this would become quickly
intractable instead hawkins claims that
evolution repurposed the ancient systems
that evolved to model spatial
relationships such as grid and place
cells it generalized those systems to
model abstract concepts in abstract
spaces
in this system thinking and reasoning
becomes a kind of traversal through a
complex topology of relationships in the
brain analogous to the traversal of a
physical space
the whole cortical sheet is made of
collections of primitive columnar units
called mini columns
each cortical area is a collection of
millions of cortical mini columns these
mini columns are organized in about six
layers with specific types of neurons
and connection patterns in each layer
neighboring mini columns have the same
receptive field so they have the same
inputs from other cortical areas and
these mini columns form complete
fundamental and primitive units known as
macro columns or as hawkins calls them
cortical columns
now pyramidal neurons are the typical
excitatory neurons in the neocortex
their name comes from the triangular
shape of their cell body the dendrites
of each pyramidal neuron connect to tens
of thousands of excitatory synapses
equally split from local and remote
sources
the neurons can look significantly
different in their connection
arrangements depending on which
neocortex layer they're situated in
the thalamus is the main input and
output subcortical structure to the
neocortex it could be viewed as the
seventh layer of the neocortex it
primarily sends sensory or pre-processed
information into layer four of the
neocortex
moreover columns in the neocortex learn
to model whatever systems are wired to
them columns wired to the ear for
example learn to process sound
columns wired to the retina rods and
cones learn to process images the
neocortex can retain remarkable
plasticity even later into life
perhaps the most striking examples are
those of post post-injury plasticity
where the brains overcome injury by
rewiring remaining neurons to regain
some or even full functionality
the cortical regions are densely
interconnected with many feedback and
feed-forward skip connections across the
hierarchy and all functional areas in
the neocortex are bi-directionally
connected with other brain structures
but their main inputs and outputs come
from other cortical areas via
long-distance connections
all cortical regions are densely
connected but there's some apparent
asymmetry and even hierarchy detectable
in the overall structure
sensory areas tend to be lower in the
hierarchy than associative or motor
areas for example and bottom-up
information flows are known as
feed-forward and top-down connections
are known as feedback connections
what should be pretty clear from looking
at this structure is that there's no
blank slate
there's a very clear cognitive
architecture and much of this high-level
structure is there from birth there are
many skip connections a high level of
recurrence with many feedback loops and
the process is highly distributed at
this point i want to draw your attention
to a paper published last year by
psychologist joseph cesario
it was titled your brain is not a tiny
onion with a reptile inside joseph
pointed out several misunderstandings of
nervous system evolution
which he says stems from the work of
paul mclean who in the 1940s began to
study the brain region which he called
the limbic system mclean later proposed
that humans possess a so-called triune
brain
consisting of three large divisions that
evolved sequentially the oldest the
reptilian brain controls basic functions
such as movement and breathing
next the limbic system
which controls emotional responses and
finally the cerebral cortex which pretty
much means the neocortex but you know he
thought that that controlled language
and reasoning
joseph said that mclean's ideas were
already understood to be incorrect by
the time he published his 1990 book i
mean since the 1970s many in
developmental neuroscience
thought that the
uh the ideas from mclean were a myth you
know due to its longevity the triune
brain idea has been called by uh
neuroscientist lisa feldman barrett as
one of the most successful and
widespread errors in all of science
joseph pointed out that the problem with
this view is a simple conception of
evolution
being arranged sequentially from the
simplest to the most complex organisms
this view implies that anatomical
evolution proceeds in the same fashion
as geological strata with new layers
adding on top of existing ones instead
most evolutionary change consists of
transforming existing parts
joseph says that the neocortex is not an
evolutionary novelty unique to humans or
primates or mammals all vertebrates
possess structures evolutionarily
related to our cortex
joseph concluded that these ideas are
consistent with traditional views of
human nature as rationality battling
emotion the tripartite platonic soul
freudian psychodynamics and religious
approaches to humanity it's also a
simple idea that can be distilled and
communicated to a lay audience
look i'm not suggesting for a second
that hawkins subscribes to the idea of a
tree in brain but i think it's possible
to get this impression reading his book
which is why i wanted to bring this up
it turns out it's very tricky to get
neurons to do this
to build a map of an environment it's
just and so we now know there's this
these famous studies that's still very
active about place cells and grid cells
and other types of cells in the older
parts of the brain
and how they build these maps of the
world it's really clever it's obviously
been under a lot of evolutionary
pressure over a long period of time they
get good at this
so animals not know where they are
what we think has happened
uh and there's a lot of evidence to
justice is that that mechanism we
learned to map
like a space
is
was
repackaged the same type of neurons was
repackaged into a more compact form
and that became the cortical column
in 1972 john o'keefe discovered the
first component of an internal gps
system in the brain he discovered place
cells in the hippocampus which activate
when a rat is situated in specific
locations in a room
more than three decades later in 2005
mae britt and edward moser discovered
another key component of the brain's
positioning system
grid cells which represented a
coordinate system which allowed for
precise positioning and pathfinding
these discoveries solved the problem
that has occupied philosophers and
scientists for centuries how the brain
creates a map of the complex world
around us and how we navigate our way
through it
what's intriguing about the brain
solution is that it seems to create
multiple hexagonal grids with slightly
different orientations and scales
because these grids are orientated and
scaled differently each point in space
activates a unique combination of grid
cells in other words the brain encodes
locations using bits in a sparse
distributed representation
jeff thinks that sparse representations
are crucial to the success of the human
brain and should guide our construction
of artificial intelligence
what's intriguing about the brain
solution is that it seems to create
multiple hexagonal grids with slightly
different orientations and scales
because these grids are orientated and
scaled differently each point in space
becomes a unique combination of grid
cells in other words the brain encodes
these cells using a sparse distributed
representation jeff thinks that such
sparse representations are crucial to
the success of the human brain and
should guide our construction of
artificial intelligence
if you're going to build a model of a
house in a computer they have a
reference name and you can then
reference them like cartesian
coordinates like x y and z axes
so i could say oh i'm going to design a
house i can say well the the front door
is at this location xyz and the roof is
at this location xyz and so on that's a
type of reference frame
so it turns out for you to make a
prediction and i walk you through the
thought experiment in the book where i
was predicting what my finger was going
to feel when i touched the coffee cup it
was a ceramic coffee cup but this one
will do
and what i realized
is that
to make a prediction with my finger's
going to feel like it's going to feel
different than this which would feel
different if i touch the hole or the
thing on the bottom
make that prediction the cortex needs to
know where the finger is the tip of the
finger
relative to the coffee cup
and exactly relative to the coffee cup
and to do that i have to have a
reference frame for the coffee
jeff says that after many years of
thinking about the function of the
neocortex he deduced that it must store
everything that we know all of our
knowledge right using something called a
reference frame
but what exactly does jeff mean by a
reference frame well consider a paper
map as an analogy a map
is a type of model
right so a map of a town is a model of a
town and the grid lines such as the
the latitude and longitude lines are a
type of reference frame a maps gridlines
is its reference frame so they provide a
structure of the map a reference frame
tells you where things are located
relative to everything else and it can
tell you how to achieve goals such as
how to go from one location to another
location
now jeff realized that the brain's model
of the world is built using map-like
reference frames not one reference frame
but hundreds of thousands of them jeff
thinks that most of the cells in your
neocortex are dedicated to creating and
manipulating reference frames which the
brain uses to plan and think
our brain's knowledge representation is
a simulation of reality and this applies
in concept space as well as physical
space as was the case with grid and
place cells in other parts of your brain
so jeff now thinks that the way we think
is analogous to how we navigate spaces
he says that the similarity of circuitry
observed in all cortical regions is
strong evidence that even high-level
cognitive tasks are learned and
represented in a location-based
framework to be an expert in any domain
requires having a good reference frame a
good map two people observing the same
physical object will likely end up with
similar maps for example it's hard to
imagine how the brains of two people
observing the same chair would arrange
its features differently
jeff said in his book that being an
expert is mostly about finding the
reference frame to arrange facts and
observations i mean albert einstein for
example started with the same facts as
his contemporaries however he found a
better way to arrange them a better
reference frame that permitted him to
see analogies and make predictions that
were surprising
what's most fascinating about einstein's
discoveries
relating to special relativity is that
the reference frame he used to make them
were everyday objects right he thought
about trains and people and flashlights
he started with the empirical
observations of scientists such as the
absolute speed of light and then used
everyday reference frames to deduce the
equations of special relativity because
of this almost anyone can follow his
logic and understand how he made the
discoveries in contrast einstein's
general theory of relativity required
reference frames based on mathematical
concepts called field equations which
are not easily related to everyday
objects einstein found this much harder
to understand as does pretty much
everyone else
jeff hawkins is one of the ultimate
gentlemen scientists of our age
his first major project was palm
computing which is a company that he
founded he invented the palm pilot in
the mid-1990s and despite his incredible
success in the nascent mobile computing
industry his heart was never in it his
passion was always for theoretical
neuroscience he knew the biggest prize
was understanding human intelligence and
then using that knowledge to create
human level machine intelligence
so in 2005 he co-founded numenta in
redwood city in california nomenta is a
machine intelligence company that has
developed a cohesive theory core
software technology and applications
based on the principles of the neocortex
its dual mission is to understand how
the brain works and to apply those
principles of real intelligence to
create intelligent machines
neuroscientists were publishing
thousands of papers a year covering
every single detail of the brain but
there was a lack of systemic theories
that tied all of those details together
nimenta decided to first focus on
understanding a single cortical column
right they knew that cortical columns
were doing something physically complex
and therefore must be doing something
complex now last week we had ben gertzel
on the show and he is convinced that
artificial general intelligence must be
a hybrid of many underlying algorithms
not a single learning algorithm jeff
hawkins doesn't agree
hawkins thinks that all the magic of
intelligence could emerge from a single
cortical learning algorithm
andrew ng
said that as a young professor and after
he read hawkins first book on
intelligence he also became convinced
that a simple scaled-up learning
algorithm could reach artificial general
intelligence
now what does seem to really distinguish
hawkins ideas is that intelligence must
emerge from diverse and strongly
multi-modal inputs perhaps that
intelligence is somehow emerging from
the nature of physical embodiment now
jeff argues that we're the first species
on earth to know the age and the size of
the universe he thinks that humans are
the first species to be known by their
knowledge
and not by their genes
that's the beauty of
this discovery that this guy vernon
mount castle made many many years ago
which is that
there's there's a single cortical
algorithm underlying everything we're
doing
the mindful brain is a small book it's
about 100 pages long and published in
1978 and it contains two essays about
the brain from two prominent scientists
one was written by vernon mel castle a
neuroscientist at john hopkins
university
now jeff hawkins cites mount castle as
being one of his biggest inspirations
jeff says that it remains one of the
most iconic and important essays ever
written about the brain
mount castle proposed a new way of
thinking about the brain that is elegant
a hallmark of great theories but it's
also kind of surprising and it continues
to polarize the neuroscience community
now mount castle noted that the brain
grew really large by adding new brain
parts on top of old brain parts the
older parts control more primitive
behaviors while the newer parts create
more sophisticated ones
however mount castle goes on to say that
while much of the brain got bigger by
adding new parts on top of old parts
that's not how the neocortex grew to
occupy 70 percent of our brain the
neocortex got big by making copies of
the same basic thing the same circuit he
says that every single part of the
neocortex is the same basic circuit
different parts of the neocortex are
different not in their intrinsic
function but rather in what they are
connected to the implications of this
are huge if we understand how one part
of the neocortex works we understand how
it all works and how all aspects of
intelligence can emerge from a single
cortical algorithm mount castle pointed
out that the neocortex grew really
quickly given the short evolutionary
time now darwin's big idea is that the
diversity of life emerged from a single
algorithm similarly mount castle
proposed that the diversity of
intelligence also emerged from a single
basic algorithm the difference is that
darwin knew what the algorithm was
random variation and natural selection
darwin didn't know where the algorithm
was in the body the discovery of dna
came much later mount castle knew where
the algorithm resided but not what it
did
mount castle said that there's about 150
000 cortical columns in the neocortex a
bit like 150 000 little pieces of
spaghetti stacked next to each other
scientists knew that these columns
existed because they all respond to
different sensory inputs
be it from a patch of skin or a signal
from the retina but the columns are
wired to different sensory inputs from
the body
there's a wonderful anecdote in jeff's
book about the last time he met mount
castle jeff gave a speech at john
hopkins university and at the end of the
day he met with mount castle and the
dean of the department the time had come
for him to leave and you know jeff had a
flight to catch so they said their
goodbyes and the car was waiting for
jeff outside
as jeff walked through the office door
mount castle intercepted him put his
hand on jeff's shoulder and said in here
is some advice for you kind of tone of
voice
you should stop talking about hierarchy
it doesn't really exist
jeff was stunned
mount castle was one of the foremost
experts on the neocortex and he was
telling jeff that one of its largest and
most well-documented features didn't
exist
jeff was surprised right it was as if
francis crick had said to him oh that
dna molecule doesn't really encode your
genes
so jeff didn't know how to respond he
just said nothing as jeff sat in the car
on his way to the airport he tried to
make sense of those parting words
today jeff's understanding of hierarchy
in the neocortex has changed
dramatically it's much less hierarchical
than he previously thought
did vernon mount castle know this back
then did he have a theoretical basis for
saying that hierarchy didn't really
exist was he thinking about the
experimental results that jeff didn't
know about he died in 2015 and jeff will
never be able to ask him
after his death jeff took it upon
himself to re-read many of his books and
papers his thinking and writing always
very insightful his 1998 perceptual
neuroscience the cerebral cortex is a
physically beautiful book and remains
one of jeff's favorites about the brain
when jeff thinks back on that day he
really laments and he kind of wished
that he would have chanced
missing his flight for that last
opportunity to talk of mount castle
further even now he wishes he could talk
to mount castle about his current ideas
he'd like to believe that mount castle
would have enjoyed the thousand brands
theory of intelligence so if you have
many brains
who are you then so it's interesting we
have a singular perception right you
know we think oh i'm just here i'm
looking at you but it's it's composed of
all these things there's sounds and
there's and there's uh there's vision
and there's touch and
all kinds of inputs yeah we have the
singular perception and what the
thousand brain theory says we have these
models that are visual models we have a
lot models of auditory models models
matters of tactile models and so on but
they vote
and so um they send in the cortex you
can think about these columns as that
like little grains of rice 150 000
stacked next to each other
and um each one is its own little
modeling system but they have these
long-range connections that go between
them
and we call those voting connections or
voting neurons
um
and so the different columns
try to reach the consensus like what am
i looking at okay you know each one has
some ambiguity but they come to a
consensus oh there's a water bottle i'm
looking at
um we are only consciously able to
perceive the voting today the most
common way of thinking about the
neocortex is a bit like a flow chart
right information from the senses is
just processed sequentially step by step
as it passes from one region to the next
in this notion
every step of neural processing refines
a representation from the low level to
the high level incrementally scientists
refer to this as a hierarchy of feature
detectors but as jeff points out even
basic study of how the brain works will
tell you that cognition is a interactive
process right depending on movement
for example to learn what a new object
looks like we hold it in our hand and we
rotate it this way and that way and we
see what it looks like from different
angles and once learned we're able to
recognize entire objects from the touch
of a single finger or a fleeting glimpse
of a small part of the object
jeff's proposal of reference frames in
cortical columns suggests a different
way of thinking about how the neocortex
works thinking of cortical columns as
cognitive primitives even in low-level
sensory regions that are capable of
learning and recognizing complete
objects
jeff's theory explains how a mouse with
a mostly one-level visual system can see
and recognize objects in the world
but where is the knowledge stored in the
brain jeff thinks that our knowledge of
objects are distributed over many
cortical columns
so when i pick up a pen there isn't a
single model of this pen
but rather thousands
i have visual models i have
sensory models i have auditory models
and everything created in between right
from a rich topology of reference frames
binding them all together and every
cortical column models hundreds if not
thousands of complete objects at
multiple scales the long-range
connections between the columns and the
regions of the neocortex communicate at
the level of classified objects not
features
jeff thinks that his theory solves the
age-old binding problem in artificial
intelligence which is the challenge of
mapping sensory input to discrete mental
categories and how these discrete
categories can be combined into a single
lived experience
jeff thinks that the binding problem is
a side effect of a flawed assumption
that the connection topology of the
brain is convergent rather than
divergent
the solution to the binding problem is
that your cortical columns vote your
perception is the consensus which is
reached from the columns voting on what
they recognize the voting works across
sensory modalities when you grasp an
object in your hand jeff believes that
the tactile columns representing your
fingers share another piece of
information their relative position to
each other which makes it even easier to
figure out what they're touching the
brain wants to reach a consensus
now in jeff's book he shows an example
of an image which can appear as either a
vars or two faces
in examples like this the columns can't
decide which is the correct object
because it's ambiguous as if it's as if
they have two maps for two different
towns but the maps at least in some
areas are identical vars town and faces
town they're just too similar so the
voting layer wants to reach a consensus
but it doesn't permit two objects to be
the same simultaneously so you have to
pick one possibility you can perceive
faces or of ours but not both at the
same time and the process of cognition
allows us to move between the
alternatives to reason interactively
over time in his book jeff makes the
powerful argument that thinking is
simply traversing a topology of
reference and displacement frames in
your brain
jeff thinks that this reasoning is
movement evolved to extend the physical
world of spaces and time to our worlds
of abstract thought the succession of
thoughts that we experience when
thinking is analogous to the succession
of sensations we experience when moving
our finger over an object or walking
around a town
perhaps the reason why albert einstein
was so smart was because of the unique
topology of reference frames in his
brain his information architecture if
you will must have been arranged as a
function of his life experiences as well
as his biology traversing his brain
topology allowed him to make powerful
abstract inferences that other people
couldn't make for him it must have felt
a bit like the borg traversing their
wormhole network in the delta quadrant
for those of you who are fans of star
trek voyager
jeff says that learning conceptual
knowledge can be difficult if i give you
10 historical events related to
democracy how should you arrange them in
your brain one teacher might show you
the events arranged on a timeline
you know in a one-dimensional reference
frame it's useful for assigning the
temporal order of the events and which
events might be causally related by
temporal proximity but another teacher
might arrange the same historical events
geographically on a map of the world
timelines and geography are both valid
ways of organizing historical events yet
they lead to different ways of thinking
about history they might lead to
different conclusions and different
predictions the best structure for
learning about democracy might even
require an entirely different map a map
with multiple abstract dimensions that
correspond to fairness or rights for
example
so what does the thousand brains theory
tell us about machine intelligence
intelligent machines need to learn a
model of the world
inference prediction planning and motor
behavior are all based on this model the
model is distributed among many nearly
identical units that vote to reach
consensus this gives us robust
prediction it scales well and it works
with any kind of sensor array and
modality and voting solves the binding
problem in each unit knowledge is stored
in a reference frame and is learned via
sensory motor interaction this means
that we can learn unsupervised fast and
the motor behavior is integrated this is
matthew taylor from numenta this place
looks really familiar but i can't
remember how i got here it's almost like
someone severed all of the distal
connections between the pyramidal
neurons and my neocortex
many years ago nomenta used to refer to
their overarching theory as htm theory
but now they use the terminology
thousand brains the htm or hierarchical
temporal memory algorithm was a
particular implementation of the early
ideas of the thousand brains theory the
original guiding principles of htm were
that it was a sequence memory algorithm
numenta thinks that every neuron in your
brain is learning a pattern of sequences
it's needed to support continual
learning and critically it wasn't an
artificial neural network which they
argued were not biologically inspired or
at least not in their popular
configuration at the time the core data
structure of the algorithm was called an
sdr or a sparse distributed
representation this was a large bit mask
think of it as a large ordered
collection of ones and zeros the
representation is sparse which means
that it typically only contains about
one percent of ones instead of zeros and
the values represented the state of
neurons in different regions of your
neocortex so nomenta really leans into
this idea of sparsity in the brain and
its necessity to build any intelligent
system the reason why sparsity is so
powerful is that there are factorially
many permutations
of values i mean for example there are
about 175 million values if you had four
on bits in an sdr of length 256 right
because it's 256 choose 4. so this means
that the possibility of getting false
positives is negligibly small it's also
space efficient because those four bits
which could represent 175 million things
could be stored in a 32-bit array right
which is four times eight bits
the notion of similarity between these
sdrs is their intersection or their
hamming distance and again the really
clever thing is just how robust these
representations are to noise you could
add about 33 percent of random noise to
both of the sdrs and it would barely
affect the overlap metric you can also
union the sdrs together and not much
information about the patterns would be
lost in the mix
so the htm algorithm needed encoders to
take any data structure and represent it
as a sparse distributed representation
encoding the information into an sdr is
an important consideration for htm much
as it is with any other machine learning
model but i was really excited you know
when i learned about htm because it
seems so audacious and each column has
a connection to this input space
and it has a receptive field so each
column is connected to different bits in
the input space and
these are proximal dendritic connections
feed forward input into
the
system
and each one of the cells within the
column shares that receptive field
through its proximal connection
we also have these other connections
between cells within the structure and
here's a third cell with another four
synapses on its segment these are distal
connections
so the cell body or the soma has got uh
different areas of receptivity
the feed forward proximal input comes
from
below
and the contextual information or the
distal connections come laterally from
other cells within the structure we're
comparing a biological neuron to the htm
you know neuron in software that we're
creating we have the feed forward input
which is the proximal dendritic input
from the input space in in both sides
and then the distal input from lateral
connections to other cells within the
space
for context now this htm neuron is
showing that there's feed forward input
but it's also showing that it can have
one or many
distal connections these are distal
segments
each one of these segments could
potentially have one or many synapses or
connections to other cells within the
htm structure each one of those cells
may be in an on and off state so at any
time if a cell wants to decide whether
it's going to go into a predictive state
or not it can look at all of its
segments
and its connections across all of their
synapses and if any one of those
summed across all the synapses breach
some threshold which is configurable
then that cell goes into a predictive
state based upon its connections its
contextual connections to
the
other cells within the structure so what
i'm doing is i'm feeding in a four note
sequence and then resetting and
restarting the sequence over so every
time it sees f-sharp the first note in
the sequence it's seeing it for without
any context
nothing came before it
so the algorithm goes and looks into
every cell in in every active column
only cells within active columns become
activated because these activations are
completely driven by
the proximal segments to the input space
there's only one segment on the cell
because it's one color it's magenta
color and all of the cells that it's
connected to
are active in the current time step
that's why it's predictive because it
looked at its segment and it looked it
summed up all the synapses and they were
all one apparently and that breached its
threshold to become predictive so it is
in a predictive state
i've never seen another machine learning
algorithm quite like it you know almost
all of them are continuous rather than
discrete and even the discrete ones like
decision trees they still assume an
ordinal value on the dimensions
hdm takes it one step further its
representations are also distributed
over the features the only encoding
rules of sdrs were that semantically
similar data should have a significant
overlap on the sdrs
the encoder should be deterministic and
the output should have a fixed
dimensionality
and the sparsity level should be similar
across the input domain now the thing
that was missing to some extent from htm
was the notion of representation
learning like we have in neural networks
you have to do it all yourself in the
encoder which is probably the main
reason why htm never took off for
unstructured data problems the reason
why cnn's dominated computer vision was
because it learned representations that
were better than any hand-crafted
representations the locality prior and
the weight sharing and the stochastic
gradient descent made it computationally
tractable
the htm neuron was inspired by pyramidal
neurons in the neocortex
a neuron is receiving sdrs from
distilled apical dendrites higher up in
the hierarchy and from basal dendrites
from the same region of the hierarchy
and also from proximal dendrites from
lower level of the hierarchy or some
sensory input which represented the
classical receptive field of a neuron
now all of these neurons are receiving a
stream of sdrs and they're figuring out
when to fire and turn on their on bit or
you know when they should go into a
predictive state which can tell other
neurons when to fire
right from the very beginning numenta
knew that real neurons are not simple
point neurons the synapses on active
dendrites detect dozens of sparse
contextual patterns and can learn
complex temporal sequences
active dendrites enable flexible context
integration in the layers of neurons
there are two primary phases of the
temporal memory algorithm the first is
to identify which cells within active
columns will become active on this time
step the second phase once those
activations have been identified is to
choose a set of cells to put into a
predictive state this means that these
cells will be primed to fire on the next
time step htm implemented dendrite
branch specific plasticity so if a cell
becomes active and there's a prediction
it reinforces that dendritic segment if
there is no prediction it grows the
connections by sub-sampling the
previously active cells and if the cell
is not active and there was a prediction
it weakens the dendritic segments
now i learned all about the htm
algorithm from watching the htm school
series of videos from matthew taylor who
worked at nomenta matt tragically passed
away last year and i wanted to
personally pay tribute to him here his
passion and enthusiasm was infectious
and he'll be greatly missed by the
entire machine learning community
well sparsity
is something that doesn't run really
well on existing hardware it doesn't
really run really well um on gpus um
and on cpus
and so
that would be a way of sort of bringing
more and more brain principles into the
existing system on a commercially
valuable basis there's a large body of
work on training dense networks to yield
sparse networks for inference but this
limits the size of the largest trainable
sparse model to that of the largest
trainable dense model
this was the case actually until
relatively recently now since the 1980s
we've known that it's possible to
eliminate a significant number of
parameters from the neural network
without affecting accuracy or inference
time
pruning can substantially reduce the
computational demands of inference when
the appropriate hardware is utilized to
do so
when the goal is to reduce inference
costs pruning often occurs late in
training now in 1995
researchers discovered that
retrospectively pruning low magnitude
connections worked impressively well
later researchers found that retraining
the prune connections
produced even better results or even
better still rinsing repeating the
process with multiple rounds of pruning
and retraining
other approaches explored adding
connections back in at random or even
focusing on non-uniform sparsity which
is to say adding the connections in
where they are most needed in the
network jonathan frankl who was on the
show last year by the way released his
lottery ticket hypothesis in 2019 which
demonstrated that if we can find a
sparse neural network with iterative
magnitude pruning then we can train that
sparse network from scratch to the same
level of accuracy
however as the demands of training have
exploded researchers have begun to
investigate the possibility that
networks can be pruned early in training
or even before training the benefit of
doing so could reduce the cost of
training existing models and make it
possible to continue exploring the
phenomena that emerge at larger scales
recently several methods have been
proposed specifically for pruning at
initialization snip aims to prune
weights that are least salient for the
loss grasp aims to prune weights that
most harm or least benefit gradient flow
and sin flow which janet made a video
about by the way aims to iteratively
prune weights with the lowest synaptic
strengths in a data independent manner
with the goal of avoiding layer collapse
where pruning concentrates on certain
layers
now um frankel pointed out in his recent
summary paper that magnitude pruning
after training outperforms all of these
pre-initialization methods most of these
methods effectively prune the layers not
the weights which to say you can perform
similarly well even if you randomly
shuffle the weights that they prune in
each layer now interestingly sin flow
and magnitude pruning work quite well at
initialization time without seeing any
data
now frankel didn't identify a single
cause for why these methods struggled to
prune in a specific fashion
initialization time and thought that
this is an important question for future
investigation
perhaps there are properties of
optimization that make pruning specific
weights difficult or impossible
initialization perhaps because the
training occurs in multiple phases
now combining gradient descent training
with an optimal sparse topology can lead
to state-of-the-art results with smaller
networks in the brain numenta argues
that sparsity is key for how information
is stored and processed they also
believe it to be one of the most
important missing ingredients in modern
deep learning
we reached out to the mentor after the
show and they're vps of machine learning
architecture and research and
engineering so lawrence bracklund and
subtite ahmed told us that at a high
level the biggest difference is that
they view sparse networks as a unique
stand-alone class of artificial neural
networks that mirror the sparsity
exhibited in the brain versus being a
derivative of dense networks created by
pruning so
not really removing redundant
connections but creating networks that
are designed to be sparse
in 2019 the mentor released a paper
called sparsity enables 50 times
performance acceleration in deep
learning networks
in that paper they pointed to the
scaling challenges faced by the current
state-of-the-art neural networks they
said that the brain is highly efficient
right requiring a mere 20 watts to
operate which is less power than a light
bulb contrast that to gpt3 which costs
millions of dollars to train
numenta believe that by studying the
brain and understanding what makes it so
efficient they can create new algorithms
that approach the efficiency of the
brain they think that the core reason
the brain is so efficient is the notion
of sparsity a sparse network is one
where all of the neurons are not densely
connected to every other in the same
cortical area
the brain stores and processes
information as sparse representations
you know at any given time only a small
percentage of the neurons in the brain
are active disparity may vary you know
from less than one percent to a few
percent of neurons being active but it's
always sparse
sparsity will lead to a massively
smaller memory footprint because only
the non-zero elements are stored
enabling the hardware to run more
networks simultaneously
gpus and tensor processing units so tpus
they are dense execution engines they
perform the same computation task on an
entire vector or matrix of data this is
a wise approach when the vector or
matrix is dense which is to say it's all
non-zero but in the dense environment we
gain efficiency by executing a single
instruction to be applied to all of the
data this is an approach called simd but
when the data is predominantly zeros
then a prodigious amount of computation
is wasted
so if you're keeping up to date on ai
hardware you might have heard of
graphcorp or cerebros cerebrus in
particular actually they've developed
this epic microprocessor with 850
000 cores and 40 gigabytes of memory on
board it's absolutely insane
not only that the chip has been designed
to support sparsity from the ground up
these cerebros cores never multiply by
zero the scheduling operates at the
granularity of a single data value so
all of the zeros are filtered out and
this in turn provides a performance
advantage by doing useful work during
those cycles which otherwise would have
been wasted not to mention the power and
efficiency savings
now recently in a presentation they
showed this graphic claiming to achieve
near linear speed up in respective
sparsity about 84 speed up for 94
sparsity
numenta released this paper a couple of
years ago before the current sparse
hardware was released and at the time
they chose an fpga which is a field
programmable gate array as the platform
to run their performance tests because
of the flexibility it provided and
handling sparse data efficiently in
addition random access to memory is far
more granular and efficient on an fpga
enabling fpga implementations to
efficiently handle the unstructured
access patterns in sparse networks now
in their paper as well as confirming the
previous results in the literature about
the robustness of sparse networks to
noise and variance error they also
realized a significant performance gain
from using the specialized fpga hardware
now my intuition is that there's no
difference at all between the
representational power of a discrete htm
type model which they used in their
previous generation
of algorithmic approaches versus an
artificial neural network the obvious
difference is that feed forward
monolithic vector space models are more
amenable to training given today's
hardware
pretty much everyone agrees that sparse
networks are better but is there
something fundamentally special about
sparsity numenta certainly seem to think
so they anecdotally point to the brain
as being sparse but the brain is
probably sparse for the same reason that
i don't decide to get up every morning
and travel to every city in the uk
doesn't seem like a profound insight to
be honest
we can take it as a given that sparse
networks suffer less from overfitting
because they're not going to be using
their precious representational power
memorizing individual challenging or
non-representative examples in the
training data
it remains unknown if the performance of
the best pruning algorithms is an upper
bound on the quality of sparse models
there's actually some really interesting
papers out there now like momentum
resnet which allow us to train huge
neural networks with a small memory
footprint but the key question is are
sparse networks functionally better than
huge densely connected neural networks
researchers from google released the
paper rigging the lottery making all
tickets winners back in 2019
the rigging the lottery algorithm starts
with a randomly initialized connection
topology and then layer by layer adds
and removes connections densifying the
layer and then specifying again using a
traditional weight magnitude heuristic
the algorithm achieves higher accuracy
than all previous techniques for a given
computational cost at all levels of
sparsity and then scored higher accuracy
than the dense to sparse algorithms now
nimenta say that they've also produced a
similar algorithm although as far as i
know it's not been made public yet so i
assume it's pretty similar to google's
approach as they pointed us in this
direction but unlike traditional dense
to sparse iterative magnitude pruning
google's algorithm allows the topology
to grow also during the optimization
which can apparently help overcome some
of the local minima
obviously the most accurate sparsity
algorithms required at a minimum the
cost of training a large dense network
in terms of memory and computational
horsepower but that approach has serious
limitations right the size of the sparse
model you can learn is strongly bounded
on the size of the larger dense model
which you're specifying from as a
starting point it's simply too
inefficient to waste computation on so
many parameters which would end up being
zero anyway
google's algorithm seems unequivocally
better than dense iterative magnitude
pruning which is somewhat surprising to
be honest given that it's uh it seems to
be doing the same thing but only one
layer at a time
now training mobile net one and two on
imagenet with this form of sparse
training was instructive it was possible
to train a sparse network with nearly
the same accuracy in about 30 percent of
the compute time
it was also possible to train a large
sparse network which was five percent
better accuracy in roughly double the
flops of training the original dense uh
version today's neural networks have
something called the point neuron which
is a very simple model of a neuron and
uh by adding dendrites to them just one
more level of complexity
that's in biological systems you can
solve problems in continuous learning um
and rapid learning so we're trying to
take we're trying to bring the existing
uh field
and we'll see if we can do it we're
trying to bring the existing field of
machine learning
commercially along with us you brought
up this idea of keeping you know paying
for it commercially along with us as we
move towards the ultimate goal of the
true ai system
now nimente is working on some really
cool stuff behind the scenes
unfortunately there's very little
information about it in the public
domain yet jeff's main aim is to realize
the vision of the thousand brains theory
in an efficient computational algorithm
sparse networks are just a tiny part of
this vision the next step is
implementing continual learning with
active dendrites and this essentially
means that they need to be able to add
new synapses and train them
independently of the existing ones
this is going to require a specified
version of backprop which will also
require specialized hardware and
algorithms to implement they also
mentioned to us that they want to
exploit activation and weight sparsity
simultaneously mirroring the neocortex
anyway
next week on street talk
[Music]
another book that i read around the same
time that had a big impact on me
uh
and and
there was actually a little bit of
overlap with john pierre as well and i
read it around the same time
is jeff hawkins on intelligence which is
a classic
and he has this vision of the people of
the main championship i hope you enjoyed
it a multiscale hierarchy of temple
prediction modules
and these ideas really resonated with me
like the the notion of
a modular hierarchy
um
of you know potentially um
of
compression functions or prediction
functions i thought it was really really
interesting
and it reshaped uh the way it started
thinking about how to build minds
let's kick off with the main show hope
you enjoy it folks well i fell in love
with brains actually when i read an
article by francis crick who was one of
the co-discoverers of dna
and francis had
later in his life turned his interest to
neuroscience and he wrote this
essay that appeared in scientific
american where soon
the emperor has no closed type of essay
he said you know what we have all this
data about the brain and it's really
wonderful we collected all this data and
we've got decades and decades but no one
has a clue what the hell is going on
and um
and he says you know we need new ways of
thinking about the brain we don't really
necessarily need more data and
and that just struck me i was 22 and i
was like holy crap you know that's just
a puzzle we have this we have these
pieces and someone has to put the pieces
together and that seemed like something
i would be good at or at least i would
enjoy
and that's got me going that was that
was the thing that just i said i'm going
to make a career out of this and then
very quickly i realized that well
you know this is the long thing it's
going to take a long time
and uh but if we do this
um then if we really figure out how the
brain works and what it does then we
will have real big insights into how to
make intelligent machines and so i said
oh my god the implications are here to
not just from a neuroscience but from an
ai point of view and so that got me
going uh on this on this journey and at
that point i decided to change careers
from engineering to neuroscience uh
computer engineering computer science
and neuroscience and start all over i
just got my my degree from the
university so i was like yup starting
again
here we are 40 years later
it's been a long journey though as you
probably probably know there's been a
lot of twists and turns too absolutely
absolutely well we really enjoyed
reading your book but um i wanted to
talk a little bit about some of the
tribalism in the machine learning
community so i've been doing a bit of
research online and
your mission right now is to try and
convince other people of of your ideas
you've got this incredibly exciting idea
of the brain and as you just said that
in in some level of abstraction the
brain is infinitely complicated but
actually if you think about it in terms
of simple rules that can produce a lot
of complexity it's not that complicated
but you know i've noticed that when you
speak to some of the machine learning
folks they are very quick to dismiss
your ideas and they say well there's
there's no material difference with
monolithic neural networks with point
neurons and back props and back prop and
you know it's good that people are so
passionate about what they believe in
but by the same token it means that
science only advances one funeral at a
time yeah
um
it's a very complex issue you bring up
here and um
uh i i think our mission isn't to
convince people
our first our mission was to figure out
what the hell is going on in our heads
that was the first thing we had to do
and we made a lot of progress on that
now we have to sell those ideas we have
to sell them to neuroscientists so we
publish papers up speaker conferences
people cite our work they test it and so
on that has to happen it takes time um
then uh then we now have a road map we
can see
we can now uh from the position i'm in
and some of the people work with me we
can see
where the shortcomings are in current ai
techniques uh we can we can see oh the
brain's doing it differently it's doing
it this way
and and we have we can have two
approaches to go forward we could say
well we need to convince everybody else
which is not really a fun thing to do um
or we can we can just put our ideas out
there document them show people them and
then work at doing this ourselves like
just demonstrate it start building
things um making things that work making
things to solve problems that other
people have been struggling with so
we're doing a bit of all these things
we're promoting the neuroscience theory
we're promoting um these ideas in the
machine learning community and we're
also implementing this stuff
uh because in the end you if you don't
if you you know you can't implement it
unless you understand it so it's a good
test for us too
um and you would wish you know everyone
wish like oh i wish everyone just you
know agreed with us where everyone you
know got what we understand but the
reality is it's a big world of lots of
big little um and there's a lot of um
people who want to dismiss new ideas um
but that's just the nature of the of the
beast right we just have to accept that
um
science is not just science you have to
promote your ideas as well as discover
them and the same is true uh in the
machine learning world
well one thing that's kind of
interesting about that
you know philosophical aspect that you
have of look it's a big world there's
lots of people doing a lot of different
things that's kind of the heart of
evolution right is that there's
variation people taking different
approaches and natural selection will
kind of sort out you know which ones
work and don't work and that's one thing
i've always thought about a lot of the
folks that don't want to pay attention
to what the brain does is they don't
have a sufficient appreciation
for how much
you know uh let's say
work has gone into designing the human
brain right i mean a billion years of
life
however many hundreds of millions of
years of intelligent evolution so
certainly we can learn things from the
neuroscience right i mean and
and
of course that was the original
inspiration for the artificial neuron
but that was just one tiny simplest
possible abstraction of a neuron that
happened what fit yeah i don't know what
50 years ago right six years there's got
to be more we can learn right
but yeah but you know the way i look at
it is we're all trying to reach the same
end goal we're all trying to figure out
how to build intelligent machines
they're truly intelligent we all we're
either intelligent uh we can talk about
the implications of that um
and i don't think there will be multiple
ways of doing this there's like in the
end there aren't multiple ways of
building computers they're all some
sense of universal turing machines and
we have variations on that um and so i
think that's what's gonna happen here
too now a priori how would i know that
engineers couldn't figure this all out
just by thinking about and doing
engineering stuff um you know my guess
was that we'd have to figure out how the
brain works first uh and who knows i
could have been wrong that was a bet
maybe people would figure it out but
here we are 67 years later in the field
of ai and i still i think today's ai
systems are still incredibly limited
they don't really do much at all with
it's intelligent that's my opinion um
they're very very restricted they don't
generalize they don't create behaviors
they don't it's just so many things that
we're so far away and now we took a long
time but now we figured out a lot about
how the brain works so now we have a
roadmap so
um i think it's going to be a lot easier
it's now it's not just like oh i think
it's going to be quicker to study the
brain and other people say no i don't
think we'll be i said well we now have
some things we can we really understand
about the brain we don't have to worry
about that anymore so um the approach we
took has been fruitful
um and um and i should also say just be
clear today's ai is really useful so i
have nothing against it yeah
it's great
um
it's just not intelligent and i want to
build soldier machines
yeah it's quite a it's really
fascinating to get to talk to you uh
your book on intelligence is actually
one of the very first books of it about
ai i ever read it so uh edward is your
fault that part of this field now
i always feel bad when people tell me i
hope it worked out okay for you
it's been it's been a wonderful journey
and i'm really glad that it was one of
my first exposures to the field in a way
it was so full of like really
interesting ideas especially for the at
the time seemed very revolutionary um
and a very well shaped my picking so i
want to ask you a little bit um appears
to me as you know someone who works
sorry i work with deep learning you know
a lot of course nowadays it feels to me
that a lot of your ideas seem uh
validated in a lot of dealery practices
um a like a currently kind of like
emerging trend is how
um
with like these me furtive societies
transfer models that have become very
popular recently that scaling these
larger is just stacking these
transformer layers seems to currently at
least increase performance in like a you
know in a pretty consistent manner and i
wonder well
it feels like that it kind of validates
in a way it's like a different proposal
to what you say but like accordingly
before we do you think there's any kind
of connection
ah
you know
i don't think about i'll answer your
question but let's just say
i'm always forward thinking i never look
back and so i don't worry about hey what
the hell was i right about this or not
or just you know somebody get credit for
with this or that i don't really care oh
so it's like let's go forward what's the
best thing you can do right now
and um
and so
you know i think there's you can
obviously as i said really we're all
going to converge on the same thing
right eventually i think so ideas become
you know i got ideas from other people
other than people get ideas for me
the history of how that
milieu of ideas
travels it's very difficult to point to
um so i i i'm very reluctant to claim
precedent than anything i just feel like
hey you know if we're all moving towards
the same idea that's great i don't think
transformers
are an implementation of the cortical
column or the cortical um algorithm idea
that we're not there yet because we know
we now know what that the core of that
algorithm is it has to do with movement
and reference frames
and uh transformers don't have that in
some sense they have a very primitive
sort of um
attentional movement if you want to
think of it that way um
um but nothing like kind of moving and
referencing we talk about so um so it's
a little bit in the right direction um
and of course they're really impressive
um but it's it's not it's not close to
what i think we need to get to
yeah it's really fascinating though
because transformers are strange beasts
they perform a kind of information
rooting and it's quite esoteric exactly
how they work and i think
in some sense they're similar to
capsules i know capsules have equated to
some of your work but i wanted to talk a
little bit more deeper than that though
so
a lot of um your ideas from a machine
learning point of view come down to the
fundamental dichotomy of discrete
representations versus continuous
representations which is what we use in
deep learning we use vectors and there
are some advantages to using these
continuous vector spaces namely that you
get for free some spatial priors so you
can encode semantic similarity as a
function of how close they are and yeah
and also you have gradients which are
useful for stochastic gradient descent
and and interestingly the manifold
hypothesis states that most natural data
falls on very smooth and low dimensional
manifolds so all of the human faces
could be projected onto a low
dimensional manifold but um i i know
that a lot of your work has has been
really solely focused on on these um
sparse distributed representations and
then um building on top in in the
encoding for example so if i'm encoding
a date representation i would do it such
that this sparse distributed
representation would have a significant
overlap for date times that are in the
vicinity yeah and so semantically
similar things should intersect each
other and spatial relations between bits
can be encoded using a receptive field
similar to you know how it works in in
cnn so um but nimenta has asserted that
intelligence wouldn't be possible
without these sdrs and they're the
primitive of of intelligence so what do
you think about the kind of comparison
between vectors and and these um
discrete representations that that you
were never yeah well let's just start
you know the whole idea of these sparse
representations comes because that's how
brains work i mean that's there's no
compression about it uh if you look in
the brain you look at any population of
cells that are representing something
at any point in time most of the cells
are inactive uh it can be anywhere from
um you know 90 percent to 99 percent of
the cells interact you just don't see of
the information carrying neurons or some
neurons that fire all the time we're not
talking about those but the ones like
information you just do not see any kind
of dense representations that is a
when you when that happens you're having
a seizure
um
and we also see that in in in real
neurons that they're not very high
fidelity they don't carry individual
spiking rates are very crude um there's
many instances where even the single the
first spike is actually the most
important thing recovering information
so we're not like this isn't so on a
high resolution you know four bits or
three bits or even even often
one bit of precision and firing of a
nerve all right so this doesn't exist in
the brain um so we just take that okay
well we need to understand why that is
and it's not just it's like more
efficient from an energy point of view
that's not what it is um it turns out
that um sparse representations have a
lot of really desirable and interesting
properties that you don't get with dense
representations um we can talk about
those um it's not like everything is um
um
there's a spectrum here right there are
some parts of the brain where you have
representations which are a little bit
less dense maybe
of the tempest
are firing and there the activity rates
really do matter um they're still not
high precision but they really do matter
and then we believe there's other parts
where they're very very sparse so i
might have five thousand neurons and
let's say two percent are active so i
have 100 active neurons and all the
information is encoded almost all the
information is coding in the population
code not in the fire rate and we can
talk about that if you want to dive into
the details with the advantage of sparse
distributed representations
um but it is an empirical observation of
the brain so you know we're gonna start
with that it's okay well why is it that
way you know
well one thing i wanted to understand
because you made the comment before that
um
they could improve generalization but
intuitively they're the opposite of
improving generalization because they
have such an incredible specificity so
for example
when i was reading through some of your
literature when you use boosting for
example in your algorithm
it increases the specificity to such an
extent but then the way we generalize in
our cognition isn't necessarily through
the representation it's through the
abstractness of of the concept we're
learning would you argue yeah so i'll be
honest with you i've changed my opinion
about this um
um i used to believe exactly what you're
saying which is like oh these overlaps
between these sdrs are really how you're
going to get generalization we now
realize it is a much more powerful form
of generalization um i talked about it
briefly in uh my new book um a thousand
brains i don't know if we really
discussed it in any of our papers yet um
and this is the idea that you're so i
can switch into that so i'm admitting
right yeah i don't think it's what i
said before okay all right we learn
um
but there's a much more powerful form of
generalization if you want i can delve
into that right now um
uh it's not okay so so we have this is
what we've learned is that each core of
a column where you say the brain in
general
um it's building this sort of uh
the model of the world you can think of
as a graph but it's you can literally
think of it as like where are things
relative to other things
it's like a computer-aided design model
right cad model it's literally doing
that you have a model of something like
a computer or your house or room or bird
or ideas that they're structured using
reference frames and data populating
reference locations and reference frames
and
um so you can imagine uh my knowledge of
something again as you know in the book
i use the coffee cup example quite a bit
but you can use anything um a knowledge
of say a stapler is is it has a certain
set of parts
uh which are then arranged in certain uh
relative positions of each other and
they have certain movements related to
each other
and um
and that structure is is that graph if
you will is the uh is the definition of
that object and that's your that's your
model of it that's how you that's how
you represent it in your brain
now when you when you learn it the way
you do this is you attend individual
components one at a time so if i if i
were to look at a new object i haven't
seen before like a stapler i would just
attend to one end or look at what's
what's this thing look like then what's
that thing look like and as you attend
to these different parts you're
essentially building this graph you're
essentially building the model you're
saying okay this component i recognize
that's like a hinge this component over
here looks like maybe a button this
component here looks a rubber pad and i
and i just start building this model in
my head but it looks my phone right
thumb up there um i started building
this mod okay so you got this i'm trying
to paint a picture in your head how you
you're doing this every moment of your
life as you look around even like you're
looking at the screen right now you're
looking to see different things you see
where they are relative to each other
i think most generalization in the world
comes about from a different from the
process of if i see something new
that i haven't seen before or i'm
experiencing something new doesn't
matter revision but just imagine you're
seeing something new you don't recognize
it you don't see this arrangement as a
familiar arrangement then you look at a
subset of the components and you say
okay let's just focus over here and you
say well these three components every
year look like something i've seen
before these look like it might be a
button that i pushed down and this thing
over here looks it might be a hinge
um and then you then you say well if
it's a hinge then a button with this
thing even i've never seen it before
maybe if i push on this button the hinge
will look and and so you you basically
your your
generalization comes about because
subsets of these graphs that you build
of the structure in the world are
similar to subsets in other graphs
you've learned
and you can say well these subsets are
similar
therefore the behavior behaviors
associated with those substances are
similar the performance of the substance
is similar so i now can ascribe to the
stapler some things i've learned about
other things um and we keep and if i see
something really new we just keep going
down into small and smaller pieces until
we find something i recognize this next
okay well i thought i recognized
and and so that i believe uh is actually
the primary way we generalize in the
world um we can talk about how str's do
that do that too but anyway
what you're talking about it sounds a
lot like sort of some of the graph
isomorphism
you know work that that people talk
about where if you if you've got this
new thing and it has all these parts and
they're in a graph you know certain
subsets of that graph may be isomorphic
to previous you know graphs that you've
seen and then therefore you can learn
about it
um and you said something really
interesting which is when you
see something new you know you attend to
kind of different parts of that and
you're doing kind of a remapping there
and there's a lot of research on on grid
cells right that they remap so when a
rodent goes into a new a new environment
it remaps the grid cells can you talk
some i mean is this related to the
remapping and i'm really curious about
how does that remap and happen
in the neurons and how quickly does it
take place you know
yeah well so one of the the the
hypothesis we have a thousand range
theory
is that well first of all we deduce the
idea that you need some that there is
any in the cortex there are these
reference frames and these structures
these graphs right we can deduce that
it's like okay well i know this is
happening i walked through the logic
behind that
and then it was at first to me it was
very odd like how could neurons build
these graphs right how and how do they
structure them i mean it what with the
way i used to focus is like my cortex
knows where my finger is relative to the
thing it's touching like relative to the
thing it's tilting not relative to my
body
and and so i use the example of coffee
cup and the coffee cup blows around so
the reference brand has to move the
coffee up i was like holy crap how does
that happen it's really hard for neurons
to do this and then of course we looked
into the literature of the hippocampal
complex which is grid cells in the
anterional cortex and place cells in the
hippocampus and there's a whole bunch of
stuff and there's there's a 20 year or
30 year history of research in this
field it's not in the neocortex but it's
it's something that's very related to
the neurocortex um
and and so and that's what they it's
clear that grid cells and place cells
and these other types these vector cells
that exist there are building maps just
like this um and so we said okay well
it's likely then that the
the same mechanisms that are used by
grid cells are probably going to be used
in the cortex
and the time we made that
that was a purely evolutionary argument
it was like saying it seems unlikely
evolution is going to discover something
like this twice it's really hard to do
right it's really really hard to do this
so and animals have to know where they
were in the world a long time ago so
they probably evolved this complex
mechanism from knowing where they are
and now the brain's gonna use that same
mechanism for knowing where like your
eyes are or your fingers are or you know
it's gonna be the same mechanism for
everything else
and so we just said hey it's probably
likely that the same basic mechanism
that uses good cells and place cells and
vector cells is going on cortex at the
time we made that that prediction we
were not aware of any evidence of that
was the case um and now there's a lot of
evidence for it now people are finding
fit cells throughout the cortex um so so
the general idea i'll keep get into your
details in a moment but the general idea
that hey the same mechanisms are work in
both places seems to be right
and and now we don't understand those
mechanisms completely even though there
are 30 years of research on grid cells
and place cells it's there's still some
mysteries about them
um but there's still a lot but there's a
lot that's known
and so
um we can map on the concepts i was
talking about like okay
um where am i where am i in this graph
what's what do i place in that graph you
can think of that a little bit like
place cells
um in grid cells you can think of
remapping is um there's two types of
remapping like this is a whole new thing
so let's just start with a new graph or
versus let's fix the graph i already got
you know
and uh and that's that's very much
related as you said to remapping of grid
cells not that we understand that
completely we don't no one does um but
we know a lot about it it's a very very
technical field in the neuroscience
solution right
i've been fascinated by douglas
hofstadter he has a really um
interesting idea on cognition and he
says that cognition is a little bit like
the interstate freeway
um in the sense that we we have this
ability to make analogies and this is
something that current ai systems cannot
do and a lot of the symbolic folks are
saying well
of course deep learning models can't do
it you're just interpolating on a
manifold for goodness sake but um your
conception of reference frames i i found
fascinating because they're not just on
your sensory inputs there's
you actually said that thinking is a
little bit like traversing through
concept space through these reference
frames and that's absolutely fascinating
so but the thing is when we learn
information many of us learn information
differently but we learn the same
knowledge and the same facts you know we
we we all know how to speak um the same
language and you did allude to this in
your book that there are some
interesting differences in the topology
of how you learn information but we
still seem to be able to reconcile it in
the same way
yeah well sometimes you know it's it's
like the way i view it uh again we're
telling stuff that some some of this
hasn't been published anywhere yet um
but the way i view it is um
if i think of myself as this part of the
cortex says the cortical call
um i don't know what come my input
represents
and i don't know where i am in the world
i don't i just don't know anything i'm
just a bunch of neurons right and so i
have to discover what i'm getting i get
two pieces of information i get some
sensory data and i also get information
about how my sensor is moving
in the world yeah we can talk about how
that happens but i get i get some
knowledge and so i have to figure out
on my own what is the dimensionality of
the space what kind of space is it i i
don't have a preconceived it's not like
oh the world is three-dimensional i
don't know that
um i don't know if it's two-dimensional
three-dimensional or in-dimensional i
just kind of figure out i have to figure
out what is the structure of which i'm
going to to place this information and
when you and i look at a chair we both
see it as three-dimensional we it is a
three-dimensional object we're going to
build three-dimensional reference frames
for that chair they're going to be
pretty similar it's going to be hard for
you to have a representation of the
chairs it's significantly different than
mine
um but when we look at things that we
might not sense directly something that
someone tells me about or i'm reading
about in a book the kind of reference
frames you and i might create for the
same facts could be very different
and and so we can arrange the same data
in different reference frames because we
can't directly sense it we're basically
relying on information coming from other
people
and so we can end up with like the same
facts represented differently and reach
to different conclusions and this is why
we have different beliefs about the
world it's almost always about things we
can't sense directly if we can sense
them directly then we generally have the
same belief about it you know
but
numb the same kind of structure so i
think this is a fascinating idea um
and um
uh but it's it's really fascinating to
me is that there is no pre
a notion about the dimensionality of the
world that a column is looking at and
and the data so it can represent almost
any kind of data as long as you can
could figure out from a movement vector
in a sense lumen data and sense data
they can say can i build a map of this
thing that makes sense the predictive
map
and um
uh and if i can i said okay that's my
that's my understanding of it another
another beautiful thing about it is is
the fact that your brain is is creating
these binary encodings at all like i
when i was researching this i found it
very interesting that for
grid cells there is some some topography
at least in the visual cortex or in the
visual layer i'm sorry so you know grid
cells that are nearby each other will
have like a similar orientation but
maybe a different scale
but once you go up a level higher so
those things create the sdr you know
they create these bits that are very
sparsely populated and then the place
cells correspond to combinations of
those
those bits to indicate a certain
location and once you're at that layer
there is no more topography it's like
now they've become truly digital
encodings of information right
well i'm not sure i'm not sure i
understand that because i it's my from
my understanding there's always going to
be a topology you're never going to lose
it uh you may not see that topology in
the place else right
um
all right that's that
i mean this
the neuroscientists who listen to white
listen to this i don't i don't want to
insult them because i'm going to make
this very simple i say you can think of
like place cells are like what
and grit cells are like right
okay so
um and you can say well this thing the
what thing is at this location type of
stuff and so if you just look at the
place cells you don't
this isn't
because they actually do uniquely encode
places so this is it gets a little
confusing here but um
uh but you can think of it just
generally like that um if we're going to
go deeper about this we're going to
start getting into all the unknowns
about grid sales and play cells and
they're very interesting
the unknown and weird properties um we
actually think now that um
this is work that one of our employees
marcus um is doing is we think actually
the the better way to think about a
coding is not the location is not
actually through the grid cells but
through these vector cells things are
things like optic vector cells and so on
um it's it's in the the grid cells
actually might just play a very
interesting singular role they might
play the role of what we call path
integration which is like if i'm moving
in a certain direction i have to be able
to predict where i'll be
uh as i move that's called path
integration i'm going to predict
something i have to know where i'm going
to be when i get there um
and that most of the max the graph
itself is not built up of grid cells
it's built up these objects these these
more like these polar coordinate cells
called vector cells
um so again this is an evolving field
and you know and even stuff we wrote a
couple years ago we're like oh maybe
that's not right it's like this but the
overall principles are the same it's
still a graph it's still you know
data at locations in this graph
um
that hasn't changed uh it's just like
how's the graph actually constructed
that's a little tricky right i mean it's
like it's fascinatingly deep it's just a
fascinatingly deep feel but if i can
just tie this back to
sdrs because i know there's there's
always a lot of
really confusion or uncertainty about
the value of sdrs and just for our
listeners sake i wanted to share one
intuition and get your take on it which
is if we are representing let's say
location uh in some space
if all we need is 20 bits to do that so
we really only need 20 bits of
information to represent
a space location to the resolution that
we need then if you go further than that
if you have 10 000 bits and you decide
i'm not going to use 20 i'm going to use
all 10 000 put like you know little .01
values kind of all throughout there
really you're just creating noise and
that other space that you could have
been using for
other purposes right and so i think
that's one advantage of the sdrs like
what do you think about that intuition
that's that's a little bit correct i i i
i haven't thought of it that way um
let me give you some let me just give
you my take on some of the advantages of
seos so let's say i'm going to represent
uh something i have 5 000 neurons i'm
going to represent so
all right so let's talk about the
capacity and let's say i'm going to use
a 2
sparsities so i have 100 active neurons
and five four thousand nine hundred
um they act if not
and um
first thing you say what is the capacity
of the system how many different
representations you can represent so
that's that's just five thousand choose
you know 100 and it's you know gazillion
because i'm in gaza
so then you can say okay so there's no
representational capacity you then you
see if i randomly chose these sdrs um
what is their overlap well they'll
overlap by about two neurons each
because each neuron is going to
participate in every 50 patterns um
but not by a lot more you won't find two
patterns randomly overlapping by 50 bits
or 30 bits it's all statistically
impossible
so you can now you have all these these
patterns you can pick randomly all day
long
and they're not going to overlap so
they're very unique
each one is going to be extremely robust
to noise so you can add 50 noise to any
of these patterns and they're still
going to be recognized correctly okay so
very noise robust is another um thing so
high capacity uh representation is very
noisable there's another property that
uh we think is being used everywhere
which is really interesting i don't know
if there's any equivalent to it other
types of networks is what we call the
union property
where
i could invoke um not one pattern but
two three five ten poundings at once
and
so now instead of having a hundred
neurons active i say i vote ten patterns
i'm gonna have a thousand neurons active
thousand out of five thousand
well it turns out that all the
processing that you do still works on
all those you can process them in
parallel there's you get even though
you're you're mixing these things
together the other ends the neurons that
are that are detecting these patterns
don't get confused and you can show this
mathematically so instead of
representing probabilities like a
probability distribution you might think
about the brain often relies on this
union property which is you know there
are multiple possibilities right now
it's not really a probability
distribution it's just like these are
all possible things that could be
happening right now let's process them
all in parallel and see which one works
out a superposition that's the kind of
property that
yeah i guess you could call that yeah um
and you only get the sparser you are the
more of those you can do and the whole
things become so you got this huge
capacity super noise robustness
um it only takes you know if i want to
recognize one of these patterns of 100
neurons i only have to recognize i only
have to connect to 20 of them so so
neurons typically don't really detect
mana they look for maybe up to about 20
or 30 synapses at maximum um at a time
so so all these these are other
properties all these properties come
about yeah
since you did mention capacity though i
would like to because i did see
you know
some variable statements sometimes i've
seen no problem whatsoever with capacity
mathematically we've got tons of it but
i was listening to one of your research
calls i guess and you started to
question you know capacity i think at
least in the maybe the the grid cell you
know the inter rhino cortex or or some
such so i guess i have two questions
yeah one is is capacity a concern or not
a concern and also
uh in order to make best use of the
capacity i'm sure the brain must have
some type of entanglement so you know
machine learned artificial networks we
know that they entangle representations
so the you know there's like weight
sharing between different
representations do you think something
similar is happening
in uh biological networks
well i i don't know uh the the the
machine learning uh field that you're
talking about uh and so i can't really
comment on this idea of entitlement of
weights in machine learning um
i'm not familiar with it there um
um i do i i i want to maybe correct
something about sdrs which relates to
the question you're asking
uh we think in some parts of the brain
some parts of the neocortex these very
sparse representations worked as i just
said
there are other places where there are
less sparse maybe 10 percent sparsity
grid cells is a great example
if i actually look at a population of
grid cells you know it's not like one
percent sparsity it's more like ten
percent sparse
and and even and there the activation
levels actually do matter it's not like
they matter like three digits of
precision but maybe one digit of
precision and um
and they and so
that doesn't have all the properties i
was just talking about um when you get
to like 10 you can't really do a lot of
superposition patterns
so it looks like in some parts of these
algorithms
there are sparse patterns that work on
some principles and you know and in
other parts they're very very sparse i
work on other principles it's not
everything is super sgrs you know i used
to think that but i don't think that
anymore
um i just became enamored with seoul and
i said oh my god this is really cool you
know how these things work um but i now
we now know that there are in some parts
of these algorithms you need to have um
still sparse but more dense
and activation of level matter and then
some of the capacity issues uh you don't
have those the capacity advantages and
so
um and that's clearly true with with
grid cell representations um but i i
imagine it's true at other things too i
know it's true in other rares too so
it's it isn't one size fits all here um
i do i do say we could say for certainty
that you don't find anywhere in the
braid where anything is represented by
full active you know uh fully dense
uh networks where all the neurons are
fire developed that this does not exist
doesn't mean this couldn't be useful and
it doesn't mean that we could in the
future do something like that it just
seems very unlikely to me uh i know
that's how most uh you know
convolutional nora that works with
networks work today um
but um right but you probably know
there's a lot of there's a lot of effort
going on in sparsity right now in the
classic machine learning community uh
people try to do it and we're working on
that too um
so so
i i think
there's something fundamental about the
representations we use when we build ai
algorithms
there's a dichotomy between you know the
good old-fashioned ai people they they
work at a level of abstraction higher
they try to implement the mind and us
connectionists we're trying to implement
the brain i think there's something
fundamental about that level of
abstraction that we work at so there's a
discussion between people like scott
harrison who think that computation is
raw and should happen at the lowest
possible level so just think of how
neural networks work they distribute
knowledge don't they across
lots and lots of different neurons and
then there's um uh people like krishna
swami and he's a computer scientist and
and he thinks that we should be dealing
with much higher level computational
primitives like functions and types so
um
i i guess
from your perspective because i i feel
that all of this is strongly emergent i
feel that we could work at the very
lowest primitive level of computation
and all of the magic emerges do you
think we should be doing that or do you
think we should be working higher up the
stack no i i well i think we have to
working higher up the stack um
i mean of course you can break any
system down and say it's just a bunch of
atoms it's just a bunch of molecules
right it's just a bunch of cells
um and that's true and you can theory
should be able to understand that but
just like thermodynamics says it's not
very useful to think about liquids as a
bunch of atoms right you you need to
have something at a higher level than
that
and
and so you know what i guess the
principle we that we'd assume that we
just we have now in some sense
discovered that the brain uses this
representation scheme using reference
frames and movement
now
i think that's the right level to think
about it i don't i i you could try to
extract it less than that but why bother
that is the unit that we're talking
about here we use models that are
but okay that's that's that's the thing
though but um
the brain was evolvable it evolved
within biological and environmental
limitations and and go five people say
well you know what scrap that let's just
implement the mind directly you know
and they think that functions and types
um they're not an imaginary concept that
have been invented by humans they think
that mathematical knowledge has it's
universal and it's been discovered by us
and we would be silly not to implement
it directly in this higher level
language because if you think about it
even um the knowledge that we have you
write about this in your book it's
fascinating that now there's a
separation between our genes and the
knowledge we've created as the human
race and all of this stuff now is is is
emergent our society is emergent
so why not implement it directly but why
trust because because because
you're gonna you're gonna guess wrong
right you know you're gonna say okay
well i will figure out what that
structure is what you know what is that
mind structure that we're gonna you know
and and so for example most of the you
know the good old-fashioned ai never
considered movement in their in their in
their fundamental aspects of
representation space right
um
and you know or even do you look for
what dr lanatt did was psych you know
same idea right um
yeah and so but
but now i know okay the brain builds
these structures using movement so
it it's not like it was a wrong idea of
the old ai people it just they just
didn't pick the right schema
it was the wrong
schema well could you expand on that
because the thing is um because we've
got a go-fi person we're very we're very
good friends with and he is convinced
that there is you know like the
knowledge engineering bottleneck and
yeah it it it's very very brittle and it
didn't work very well but um but you're
reading your chapter on knowledge
representation i think you were saying
our brain is it's like lots of models
when we model a stapler it's actually
lots of little models in our brain and
it's it learns a kind of um um it
analogizes the knowledge in a really
sophisticated and distributed way so
when we want to know what happens when
we press down on the stapler we run a
simulation in our mind you know what
what happens if i press down on it what
happens if i stretch it and our models
seem to um generalize to any version of
a stapler we might ever find so that
almost convinced me that we do need to
have
a lower level representation of
knowledge
lower than what lower than the the
reference frames i was talking about
well lo so the go five people say that
we should use um functions and types and
relations to describe knowledge but
do you think that's possible
i i i don't want to misrepresent go
fight because i haven't looked at that
stuff in a long time um
i
i think you can't do this at the level
of the neuron
i mean obviously brains are made of
neurons so but they're not uniform
neurons we have dozens of different
types of neurons hooked up in very
complex ways they do different functions
it's not just one big neural network
uh that structure is important
um and so
uh i think it's now become evident to me
and it wasn't this way five years ago
it's really evident to me now that at
least in the brain knowledge is
represented in this structured form
uh with reference aims and movement it's
the same inspiration that um
uniting has with with capsules but he
didn't incorporate movement as part of
that structure um
you know uh that with that you know but
now i i now i understand okay at least
from a brain's point of view
these reference frames are constructed
as i mentioned earlier they're
discovered through through movement
observing movement of the of the sensor
through the world
and um and so now we have this the the
the basic structure of if you want to
call it will fi
is is these uh movement related um um
reference frames and
placing you know
and stuff like that i i can't i don't
know how i would do it less than that i
don't know what how i want to get rid of
that now what do i do just ignore that
and go back and just put a bunch of
neurons together i don't know do you
mean could you come up with a genetic
algorithm that could have discovered
this using just traditional neural
networks sure maybe you could you know i
don't know which is the fastest way to
get there but now that i know it why
would i want to do something different i
i i maybe i'm misunderstanding your
questions
right yeah
well i i think the the the main issue is
that we don't understand the
representation you know if you look at
the open ai microscope and you can
visualize all the different neurons and
so on these objects have been
distributed in a way which is completely
ineffable across all of these different
neurons and
is that the most high fidelity possible
representation of knowledge well i don't
i don't know but well i will say now is
i currently believe very strongly that
um in the future when we build ai
systems they're going to work more like
on these brain structures and they won't
be just highly distributed mysterious
blobs of neurons right there
that's great by the way it's it's great
uh not only because of what they how
they perform but it's great because
they'll understand about a whole lot
better this you know this touches on the
issue of the the threats of ai right you
know the so many of the threats of are
based on the idea that we don't know
what's going to happen well now you
actually will know what's gonna happen
it's like you know you know i just like
to say it works like this it's what's it
you know i can't put it everything but i
you know i don't know what it's gonna
learn but i know how it's gonna learn
and what it's what it's capable of um so
i i just you know i i don't want to
debate people about this because i you
know there's a lot of smart people out
there and they may have things no things
that i don't know and they can pursue
things but from where i see right now
um it's very clear to me that okay this
is how brains do this this explains
everything explains again how we
structure all knowledge um and how it
evolved that's a big part of this and
how you know how we have this common
algorithm and it's going to be based on
these reference frames and movement and
so on and so
okay well why wouldn't i just just just
build that let's go for that um
and you know why build something else if
i understand that why build something
else i i don't i understand the point of
is it going to be better you know in the
future we will certainly take you let's
say i'm right let's say i'm right and we
build machines that work on these
principles that i outlined in the book
well of course we can very well go for
that we don't have to stick to the way
biology maybe we'll come up with a
better way of representing things in
structures and reference frames maybe it
won't be movement-based maybe something
else i don't know
but i try to do it do it build something
and get it working why would i go away
from it you know
yeah go ahead to try and steal steel man
the go-fi people it's because they think
that knowledge is universal
we discover it there is only one
representation of knowledge and clearly
in the brain
you can learn things in different ways
you can i can teach you a curriculum and
i can teach you it in a different way
and maybe in some weird way our brain
does learn some latent representation of
the knowledge which is the universal
knowledge but they're making the
argument that why don't we just
represent it the only way it can
possibly well obviously well first of
all that's not you know it clearly isn't
true i give it just like you just said i
gave the example in my book about taking
a bunch of historical facts
and arranging them along a timeline and
arranging them on a map
and you end up with different
inferences and different beliefs about
the same set of facts so
whether there is a universal truth i
don't know but clearly humans don't know
that universal truth um
we we can't know everything we can only
sense a small part of the world and um
and in in you know the vast majority is
invisible to us so who the hell knows
what that universal truth is um what we
can do is build good models and
uh and the models there isn't a
universal model there isn't one correct
model for for history right um
we might like to believe there is my
models writing yours was wrong that kind
of thing but
you know it's really easy to point out
even non-controversial things like the
timeline versus the map will lead to
different models the order in which you
train someone will matter you know
so i think we have to live with this um
and i don't think you know maybe there's
some platonic you know go five people
thinking there's some plot universal
knowledge that's correct all time i
don't know but certainly i don't think
that's accessible to us if there was
we just we just we can't we can't sense
the world both physically and time wise
we our senses only deal with a teeny
part of the world yeah it's a good part
but it's not a little teeny part
we don't even know the universal truth
about space and time is i mean
definitely true
if i could move on to some other
questions about the brain um so you of
course focus very much on new cortex as
the you know seed fuel intelligence and
i think i think you're definitely on the
right path with that i think most people
agree something similar to that but
there's also lots of other parts in the
brain that see pretty important and i'm
specifically uh interested it's like one
thing that machine learning people are
interested in is the dopamine circuit so
like the cortical basal ganglia
critical
and which seems really
it seems like alerted it seems like some
kind of learning is going on there could
you maybe say some words about that yeah
so obviously the neoprojects is
connected to the rest of the brain in
modern ways um myriad ways um
uh
it's it's not in isolation and it's a
very complex relationship so lots of
other things
um that doesn't mean you can't
understand what its circuits are doing
um but in a human and their cortex is
complexly tied to things and one of
those things is that if you think if the
neocortex is as this sort of map of the
world or model of the world well it what
should it learn and
what goals should it have
the dopamine circuitry is clearly
associated with what should we learn
when should we take when should we take
the effort to learn something which is
metabolically expensive
um and um and so somebody has to decide
that uh my basic contention is the
decision is not the neocortex's decision
right mostly it's somebody else's
decision
and um when we build intelligent
machines we'll have to figure out who's
making that decision and um it won't be
in the neocortical equivalent it'll be
in another part of the intelligent
machines equivalent
but uh there's absolutely no reason we
would have to model
the goals and um emotions and
other things that other parts of the
brain do unless you want to create
something was human-like right so you
know i used to joke that our dopamine
signal in our models is a switch i turn
it on and turn it off i can learn now
stop learning now right just manually
turn it on manually turn it off uh when
we run experiments um it doesn't have
anything you know more complicated than
that um but there's it you know the only
thing i'm claiming here is when we build
intelligent machines if we build them on
the principles in the neocortex they
have to be embodied i mentioned this the
whole chapter in the book about they
have to be embodied in some sort
physical or non-physical embodiment but
some embodiment they have to have uh you
know very sort of safeguards built in
they have to have various mechanisms for
what to learn what not to learn someone
has to provide goals uh what should the
goals of the system be uh what are we
trying to achieve right now
and um
but so those things have to exist but
they don't have to be modeled on i don't
see any reason at all to model those on
the neural circuits the way the neurons
do that that now we're getting pure
biology we're now getting into what is a
biological organism need including like
keeping your heart going and breathing
and you know making sure you have sex
and all these things um
yeah i can ignore that
just if we're going to build intel's
machines just make them a little bit um
to our purpose i guess i would say
another neuroscience question is that i
know um
you know a lot of people are skeptical
that the brain can do anything remotely
like bat propagation right i mean
there's sort of good arguments for why
that's just not possible but on the
other hand i don't know if you've seen
kind of a lot of the recent work by
blake richards at mcgill university
where he talks about
you can do something that performs in a
very similar way to back propagation
because
and especially in the neocortex the uh
the neurons there had these very long
apical dendrites and they had these
sections with these calcium channels
that can do these very long lasting
activations that trigger like spike
trains and he's saying that there are
there is evidence that you know if you
have feedback from a higher or
downstream layer back into this
the uh the apical dendrite you know
connections that that can have an effect
of creating something like back
propagation it's like stochastic back
propagation
uh what are your thoughts on that
well i'm i'm a little bit familiar with
that work and blood breakthroughs work a
little bit um i viewed a little bit of a
distraction
because
you know backpropagation's a cool idea
uh it works on classic neural networks
pretty well
um
i don't think the end result is like
kind of nerf what you see in the brain
at all i don't think the kind of
learning that that back propagation does
is the kind of learning we see in the
brain
um
and and so uh and there's lots of other
theories what those apical dendrites are
doing and why you have that stuff so
um i'm not going to say that back
propagation isn't occurring anywhere in
the brain i don't know maybe it is um
but it hasn't played a role in our
theories about the brain
and
i think a lot of people spend time
trying to shoot her in there like i'm
going to prove it to you see the brain
really is doing this it's like
well
but the paintings look like anything
else none of this stuff the brain
doesn't look like anything like you're
talking about here you're just trying to
put this you know one little piece back
prop into this thing i mean for example
just take away learning we know that
learning in a neuron lauren taught these
dendritic branches and and the synapses
are distributed on these branches uh
well this is this is key this is
critical you can't you can't get around
this this is this there's an important
information theoretic reason for this
it's it's not just some other reasons
it's doing something important from an
information point of view and and so
the whole idea of backprop working with
learning on individual dendritic
segments is i don't know what that means
right it's like it's like hard to fit in
so right to my mind it's like noise i
kind of like tuning it out saying well
if they figure out something really
important they'll let you know well i
mean
i'll pay attention to it yeah i think i
think more his his motivation and i
quite agree with this it's about taking
inspiration from the brain so this
algorithm that they discovered by kind
of looking for things that could you
know at least enable
you know feedback mechanisms for the
training is it but are they are they
taking information from the brain are
they taking inspiration from the neural
networks and trying to figure out what
the brain could do what they're trying
to do is they're trying to figure out
how can the brain do
deep training how can the brain do
deeply
and they like assuming that that's what
that assuming back prop is what they
want no no i just want to know can it do
how can it do deep learning and so then
they look very carefully at the biology
and they find this this alternative
mechanism which can produce results that
are very similar to back propagation but
actually it's slightly better in some
ways and so it's leading to inspiration
for how to improve ml and i guess that's
the question i really wanted to ask you
which is i always ask this what's
missing question okay so we have
artificial neural networks clearly
they're a very stripped down you know
micro abstraction of what happens in the
brain if you could add in a few things
like just
one two three kind of abstract
properties to neural networks today
what would you suggest
should be added to get the biggest bang
for the buck like how can we
incrementally improve them
okay well so so that's what we're doing
at nemesis right now so um my colleague
subatomi ahmad who's really the machine
learning expert i'm more of the
neuroscience guy
um
he put together a road map well we did
it together but he's implementing it uh
a road map the idea is like hey we have
these grand theories about the neocortex
and so on again maybe the right maybe
they're not but we think they're right
um
well what do we do next like what do we
do right so the answer question was well
how we incrementally get from where we
are today
uh machine learning to where we want
where we think we need to be some number
of years from now
and so we literally have a roadmap and
we started off by saying okay
uh first i'm going to focus on sparsity
and so we've been doing that and we've
been at
uh
we've been making really interesting
progress some of it which we published
and some some of it we haven't yet uh
about introducing sparsity to
uh first we did it for the convolution
neural networks and we did for other
types of nerves now we're doing it for
transformers
um
and showing that we can speed these
things up
and make them more robust and and i'm
talking speeding things up by a lot not
a little bit but a lot uh depends on the
network depends on the world through all
these different things but uh how do and
then how do you implement that on heart
so we start with sparsity the next thing
we're working on is the dendritic
computation because what the dendrites
get you and we haven't really talked
about this much at all so far but with
the dendrites each individual section of
a dendrites like its own little complete
computational pattern recognizer
um they allow you to represent
information in different contexts
and so um
uh
this is we think it's going to make it's
far far less training data
to train existing networks um um and so
and allow us to do continuous
well because when you train a neuron you
don't train all the synapses you only
you only modify a few on on one of these
dendritic branches and so you can you
can learn without forgetting things
um so we're working on that so okay take
existing networks make them so that
they're going to be continually learning
or they they don't forget things
um and make them so you can train them
for fewer data points
and then so we're we're well into that
now
um and then the third thing with the
next big one which is sort of biting off
the whole concept of reference frames
and um
we're just starting that
um and it probably will take several
years um but and then finally we do the
whole the whole thousand brains theory
we have lots of these columns and so on
so at least we put together we have a
road map we're working to it i think i
i'll be honest with you i think this the
progress we've made is actually far
better than i thought it would be
i thought it would take us longer to
achieve the things we're achieving uh
the performance gains we're getting are
really really something
dramatic
and uh without losing accuracy um so
uh that's that's what nomento is working
on and i don't think we've talked about
this road map um but we haven't given
all the details of it yeah so it's not
public yet the roadmap
well the rare map because i've talked
about it in like you know talks i just i
just spoke about it here right so i have
pictures of that stuff um
but the details how we're doing it like
we've created we've discovered like you
talk about sparsity the problem is you
want to run sparse networks you want to
run them on some hardware right what
kind of heart are you going to run mods
is it gpus cpus fpgas well we're doing
all of those
um but they all have their problems and
issues and because gpus don't like
sparse networks at least you don't get
any benefit from them and um and fpgas
are hard to use but they're pretty
they're good but they're really hard to
use um and
and so
that will be discovered and including
very recently we've discovered tricks um
engineering tricks that allow you to map
sparse networks onto some of these
existing architectures uh better than we
think anyone else has been able to do by
pretty large margin
and so um that you know these are very
engineering problems uh they're not pure
you know they're not pure
theoretical problems they're very big
engineering problems and we have to be
able to solve those because it's no good
to say hey spartan is great if you can't
run it faster on something you know
it's gotta really work in the real world
so it's exciting and we'll see how far
we go but right at the moment it's going
great i'm really thrilled about it uh
we've actually decided to invest more in
it because uh we're hiring more people
because it seems to be working so well
so we've been talking a lot about
intelligence uh you know however that
might exactly be defined i think rural
on campus pitch what we need when we
talk about intelligence the video cortex
is this map this ability you know
however you might exactly want to define
it but we've also talked you know we
we've um a little bit moved you talked
about motivations about you know which
may you know relate more to dopamine or
whatever you know in the brain there you
just run on your cortical intelligence
so in your book use you and of course
dedicate
a
good chunk of it to these questions of
motivations risks of benefits yeah and
you describe yourself as someone who is
pretty skeptical about like severe risks
um so
one of your one of the things which i
fully agree with by the way is you very
phenomenally describe how intelligence
is kind of like having a map either the
map itself has no immunizations it's not
good or evil it's you know it's just a
tool it could be used to do something
nice or something good you know or it
could be used to do something bad um the
map itself
is you know it's orthogonal to these
kind of questions of motivations and you
know
good or bad it kind of feel the human
idea of you we can't get it out from the
news
but at some point of course when we
actually build these systems we don't
want a lot to be in there right you know
we do want our system to actually do
things at some point we'd only grow
about sitting there and know everything
but never take the actions and the book
you for example gives you the example of
you know we want them you know to go to
mars and then you know build a colony
and not just sit around the sun all day
you know thinking about the universe or
whatever so at some point we have to
introduce some kind of motivational
system the brain seems to solve this
according to this which called the old
breed
and um i'm not sure exactly which parts
you found of the oval prey and versus
the newborn but some of perfect obvious
you know we have circuits that give us
hunger or you know you have other
motivations or whatever but
it's and
but it seems like these parts are will
be very important that okay let's assume
your project goes fantastically here 20
years in a mentor is the biggest ai
company in the world
yeah you figured out the neocortex
you've created a wonderful algorithm
on
at some point we have to inject
motivation i'm sure you agree with yeah
and we have to assure that those
motivations aligned here in like what we
want and that seems like a hard problem
maybe if you talk a little bit about
that well i don't know if it's a heart
problem
i think the concern that people have
about this is that these machines will
evolve their own motivations
that that or somehow they they are some
sort of
you know epiphenomena disappears
um
and um
i i don't
think that's right um
i think we will have to work hard to put
them in there like i mentioned earlier
um it will not be easy uh we'll have to
design what how these systems work um
unless we put this machine in some sort
of evolutionary
um structure whether it's a
self-replicating machine or it just uses
evolutionary algorithms genetic
algorithms to decide what its
motivations are
um
they won't modify themselves they won't
change on their own you know um i i gave
the very simplistic example of a
self-driving car but i think it's a
correct example you know i tell the car
where i want it to go it's not going to
decide to go someplace else because
today it feels different you know it's i
could make a call that does that but why
would i do that i'm not going to design
a car to do that so if we send roll rods
to mars
to build uh machines i'll have to be
motivated
to solve the tasks they've been given um
and but we will also build in all kinds
of safeguards just like we built in
safeguards into cars and we won't allow
the machines to you know it won't be a
mysterious process it'll be
like a self-driving car it's not going
to be something we don't understand that
happens and runs away from us
it will be difficult to do we can make
mistakes we can put in bad things and
machines will do bad things but it's not
like the machines on their own are going
to do this it's not like we've just
enabled this beast that's just going to
take over
and decide on its own what its
motivations are
so i make it very clear in the book that
there are a lot of risks with ai and a
lot of bad things can happen with it but
i
my only contention is that the fears of
existential risk
uh are overblown i don't think it's true
at all and that the arguments don't
really hold up
um because there are more arguments
based on ignorance as opposed to some
detailed knowledge of how these things
are going to work
so did i answer i absolutely agree with
you uh i i happily agree with you that
these like epiphenomenal explorations or
naive you know a lot of like sci-fi
depictions are like the robot becomes
conscious it wakes up and it decides to
rebel against its master of course
that's
a pretty silly person not everyone
thinks that's silly by the way so i i i
know i i and i'm well aware that on
everything facility but i feel there is
a stronger a similar argument that's i
don't consider the same argument but has
similar consequences and
in a way it's kind of like in your book
you have a chapter titled how the new
tortex can thwart the old brain
and you yourself describe the old brain
as the motivational system and now
you're describing the neocortex the new
brain plotting to thwart the goals put
in by you know the you know our creator
you know evolution or whatever so it
seems like
our why wouldn't our machines maybe have
similar capability interests to like
modify their own old brain quote unquote
that's interesting um
uh yeah i can see your point there
um let me see i no one's ever asked me
that before so let me just think about a
second um
well
um
the way i view that with the you know
the old brain's trying to sort something
okay so first of all then yeah the new
bridge is going to like overtake the
open so the new the neocortex that's it
has a model of the world
and the model is very consistent and it
strives to have consistent models it
wants it wants to make its model correct
that's one motivation it has if it sees
something wrong it tries to correct it
in this model
so he has this model of the world and
says okay the world ought to work like
this if a happens a b happens and c
happens
and that's good
uh but then you know the old break comes
along and says nope we don't we're not
going to do that we see a and b we're
going to go x
and uh
and so
it violates the model in some sense
right it's like while it's the model and
so
um
generally the new neocortex
uh is not able to overcome the older
brain things it just we just give in to
our desires and emotions uh but we just
struggled with it
um so i guess you're saying where does
the motivation for the from the
neocortex come how does it decide that
its model is more important than the old
branch model
um and i i don't it's a good question
i'll have to think about it some more
but i think that the root of it will be
that the motivation the true and only
motivations the neocortex has is to make
its model the world correct
and to fix errors
um
and um that is it says this isn't right
my model says this isn't right
uh we you know i want to correct my
model but i'm being told not to or i'm
being told to do things that are
violating the model
um
and so that is its motivation now
you could take that to some extreme
let's get a little sci-fi here right
you could take this to some extreme and
uh say well um the neocortex really
figures out how the world works the
future brain ai and neophytes really
figure out how the world works and
humans got it all wrong you know uh
let's let's bring it to an example we
could we can relate to there is no god
all right i know i figured this out
there's no god you guys all believe in
this but it's not true
so
uh what do we do about that is is this
ai system
uh put up with it or is it or does it do
something about it or does it just keep
trying to prod humans to do something
differently um i don't know it's a good
question i think you bring up that's a
very interesting
philosophical question
um
i will say this i don't think this is
something that's going to happen fast
quickly overnight you know it's it's
it's not this is something we don't have
time to think about this quite a bit um
but it does bring up a question what if
what if the the world as as a smarter
machine unknows it violates the world as
we'd like to believe it
and that's really the the the friction
you're talking about and um
what should we do about that there's an
even more direct like kind of physical
assault on this that doesn't require
much philosophy it's just what about the
traditional mechanisms that created life
which is variation and
you know random variation and natural
selection so for example if we send
robots to mars to build a colony
they're going to get damaged and
destroyed a boulder is going to fall on
them so they're going to need to be
programmed to replicate themselves
they're going to have to be programmed
to build replacements of themselves and
they're not going to be able to do that
with absolute 100 fidelity so errors
will creep into the
the neurons or the silicon neurons or
the programming or whatever and so
you've already got in place
the requirements for evolution which is
information transfer or self-replication
oh
i'll push i'll push back on that first
of all uh
uh hanging uh robots self-replicate is
really really hard are they gonna build
their own semiconductor chips you know
are they gonna you know mind their own
you know titanium i mean i don't know
but but but even if they do
evolution requires a very complex
structure for
um
how information is represented and and
requires that information be changed
constantly in our offspring right you
know so when we build we build you know
computer chips of nvidia builds index
chip they they're all pretty much going
to be identical
um so i i push back on the idea that
there's inherent evolution built in any
kind of self-replication i don't think
that's true i think we're if it if
there's some variation it would be very
very minor and and and it's not going to
be passed on genetically to somebody
else you know there's going to be some
blueprint how to build this ship which
is the neocortex the blueprint itself
isn't changing so if i if i if i build a
neocortex from the blueprint that
slightly got an error in it that's not
going to be propagated to its children
um
so i think there's a lot of ways you
there's a lot of things you have to do
to create evolution it's not easy
um and i don't think that's going to
happen accidentally so i'm pushing back
keith
i don't think that's going to happen
you know
it's good it's good to think about it
ask that question right right but you
know i don't think so i think in reality
if you're sending robots to mars but you
know in the chapter in the book i
mentioned this point that we could send
robots across the universe and then they
would have to self-replicate right
and after i wrote it i said oh damn i
don't know how to do that i just don't
know how you know a fleet of robots you
know ai systems appear on another planet
in some distant part of the galaxy and
they have to replicate themselves what
would be the physical form of those ai
systems that they would be able to do
that in any
reasonable amount of time and effort
because you know
just think about again i mentioned like
semiconductor factories right you know
it's like they're gonna build those
things you know how do they do this so
it made me it it was a hole in my
argument that we could send ai systems
across the universe
and i didn't put out pull out the whole
i said to myself well
i i excuse myself in this regard by
saying well you know what if we're going
to send ai systems to other parts of the
universe they're not going to be built
of silicon chips
there may have to be some other
manifestation that like biology is able
to replicate uh on its own without the
use of um these complex uh other systems
like semiconductor factories
and um but we're so far from knowing how
to do anything like that today that um i
don't know
and then maybe we'd be in trouble right
we send these things over there they
evolved and they come back and yes i
don't know
but we're talking a long time from now
yeah that's for sure there is a kind of
failure mode of thinking you know too
far ahead into the sci-fi future and
you're just kind of generalizing your
fictional evidence yeah you know yeah i
guess what i um so what i have taken
from like your your obsession your book
didn't for now kind of about like
motivations and essential risk is that i
think actually uh at least except
essential risk people that i personally
find interesting they agree with you in
like a lot of ways actually in that i
think a lot of them are very reasonable
in the sense of saying like you know
whether it's fast or short it's kind of
like you know it's kind of beside the
point and you try to see you know humans
already kind of you know hard to control
and like you know it's like if you
actually try to think about how would we
write a motivation system because you
know it can't really be a learning
system because you know like in your
book you give an example where if the
brain comes up with two ways to get to
food and one of the path has a tiger on
it the old brain will say you know kind
of like oh no don't go there but you
know the whole brain how does it know
that a tiger is bad that's like also
like
not obvious to me
how we would necessarily learn that so
i guess it just it feels to me that um
as you so say you're focused on the
neocortex which i think is an important
thing to be working on but maybe we can
agree on that some work on these
motivational systems and control
problems might also be justified oh yeah
sure i'll totally agree with that um i i
think it's justified and necessary
but i'm not scared of it and you know
the the conversation sometimes people we
shouldn't be doing this research because
it's going to get out of control aren't
you kidding me it's gonna be so hard to
do this at all you know nothing's gonna
get out of control um so we need to do
that we should do it the conversation
we're having today is great about that
kind of stuff but i guess it's just not
you know this there are quite a few
people feel this existential risk is you
know upon us and and in any day now you
know it'll be too late therefore you
know we have to stop all this stuff and
i it's just i can't see that in any
possible scenario but yeah we have to
think about these things right we have
to figure out not because i'm it's scary
or dangerous because we have to figure
out because we have to do it and and i
use the example of the book about you
know we put in safeguards my car doesn't
always listen to me when i if i'm about
to hit something my car puts the brakes
on even if i put the accelerator down
ignores me well we have to put in some
some fail-safe systems too
um in these systems so they don't you
know end up damaging things
but it all has to be done
i had a question on on intelligence i'm
fascinated on the nature of intelligence
and you were saying in your in your book
that you know the traditional go-fi
people had a task specific skill
conception of intelligence and then it
moved towards more of a
flexibility model so being able to learn
and there's also a really interesting
tradition in cognitive science about
embodiment which i think is fascinating
and you know my favorite person is
francois chorley he says that
intelligence is the infamous well i
think he says it's the task acquisition
efficiency and generalization but but
also quite you know now we've been
talking about this a lot and there's
this interesting idea that you can think
of intelligence as the ability to um
acquire knowledge so almost all of the
knowledge that humans acquire in their
lifetime is is not empirical in trial
and error it's given through instruction
or reasoning and deduction and
some some magic happens with these
intelligent systems you know why why can
we deduce so much knowledge
is that a question to me
yes
uh
why why i mean mechanistically well how
do we do that
i mean i i think i've i thought i
answered this earlier so maybe i'm
i don't want to repeat myself too much
um and maybe i don't understand the
question
um well for example you know you knock
the beer bottle off the table you can
now reason that the floor is wet someone
might slip up on on the floor
yeah so almost all of the the knowledge
that we that we have around the world
is deduced or well it's it's it's
deduced that knowledge that you had to
learn that through observation
if you had never experienced liquids and
you never started slipping on liquids
you never experienced knocking a cup
over you wouldn't know what's going to
happen
i mean that's what kids do little babies
do this right they're like oh look what
happens
that we could live in a world where
liquids fall up and that would be a
perfectly good world and that's what we
learn
um
so i won't think we deduce this we
observe it
and and then by analogy we we predict uh
how other things that are similar would
behave similarly
uh but i think you know to me the way i
look at it is you're born with this with
this structure in your head that is
designed to learn the world through eyes
and ears and touch
um but it really in the neocortex knows
almost nothing about what it's going to
learn the old parts of the brain that's
not true
right refining refining questionnaire
because i'm i'm also fascinated by this
concept that i learned it from the first
time in your book that the neocortex now
i was going to say blank slate but keith
would kill me for saying that it's not a
blank slate it's a template because
there's actually there's a lot of
evolutionary knowledge that's gone into
there yeah yeah because you because you
can think you know it's just learning
all these signals but just the way the
ear has evolved over time that the
information gets encoded in a certain
way the cochlear has the logarithmically
spaced bands and so on so it's learnable
because it's been encoded in in a
certain way but people like chomsky they
say that we have a kind of universal
grammar or language built into our
brains and it was endowed by evolution
so where do you kind of draw that does
he say that about all knowledge about
the actual language i thought he just
said that about language
about language yeah yeah yeah so i don't
know i mean but we're we're talking
about all knowledge now right
so like
it's so you know
so i think look there is there's all
these assumptions about the how how the
cortex is connected to things
right and how it's internally connected
that have been evolutionary advantageous
and so you know we
we only see certain spectrum of light
because that's a good spectrum to look
at and we only certain types of you know
sensory inputs because those are things
that we process them before they get to
the near cortex so that they're in the
right form for the neocortex to work um
we allocate a certain amount of our
neocortex to these different sensory
modalities because that seemed to be the
right thing to do from an evolutionary
point of view
um and so there's a good good example to
say it's like a template that's right
but the in the ins what's actually
learned in that template is
is um
is unknown in terms of language i i
hated it this when i talked about
language in the chapter about high level
thought in the book and i don't consider
myself an expert in language at all um
but it occurs to me that if vernon
melcaster is right that there is a
single cortical algorithm that's
basically running everywhere the
language has to be somehow
fundamentally
mapped on to this
algorithm for century motor modeling
through reference frames and i made the
analogy about a big part of languages it
has to do with um
recursion and a recursive structures and
and the algorithms in the in the column
are really good at that um and so to me
i would say that
you know if i would take this isn't it i
never thought of this but if i would say
take
the idea
that there's a universal language i
would extend it beyond what we call
language i would say there's a universal
uh structure to everything in the world
that we can learn not everything in the
world but everything in the world that
we can learn and um that universal
structure
is this this uh reference frame central
motor idea
and um
that universal structure can learn any
language whether it's spoken language or
computer language or written language it
can learn
any structure that fits into that
algorithm
and that could be you know how staples
work and how birds fly and how evolution
occurs these are all everything we know
has to fit into that structure so in
some sense i would i would agree with
chomsky i just think he only focuses on
quote language um where i would say the
universal algorithm is
language is a subset of the universal
algorithm that chomsky talks about
that's an interesting idea i never i
never said that before stuff man we'll
see how it feels about tomorrow
but but there's there's a fascinating
dichotomy though isn't that because
it's similar to the um bias variance
trade-off in machine learning so you
know evolution has has given us a
certain prior and a certain default
encoding and then we have this
learnability algorithm and then what
fascinates me is how externalized so
much of this stuff is so there's
embodiment there's all the knowledge in
in society that we we learn language
we're brought up by our parents and and
we we acquire the language around us so
how much of it is being pushed down from
society and how much of it is being
pushed up from the prior knowledge that
we've evolved and inherited well i would
i would say there's three things there
is the our knowledge we inherited
there is what we learn on our own
just to exploratory behavior
and then what is passed down which is
always always through language but it
could be also through by observation of
other humans
um
and um
and what's the balance between those two
well i think in terms of the neocortex
it's not a lot from the biology and the
evolution in terms of the other parts of
the brain it's very much so
you know there's a
if there's evidence that says the prayer
collectors is like the old visual system
um it it it detects snakes and spiders
so people were scared of snakes or
spiders it's not the neocortex is the
old by going ah start a snake it looks
like a snake
and so you know that's not learned it's
there it's hard to get rid of um
so there's some of that but you know our
ability to walk we don't learn to walk
we actually are programmed to walk it's
just that we did we haven't finished
developing
yet until when we learn to walk we're
really just our nervous system is
finished being growing
you don't really learn to walk so these
are these old priors lots of them um and
as a human they're very very important
you know eating and sex and and
uh body functions and you know survival
all these things and all there uh but
from the neocortex point of view i'd say
there's very little um it's more just
assumptions about the the
the sensory types of sensory data you're
going to get i mean it's what you know
what strikes me tim is it's incredibly
we are so incredibly versatile on what
we can learn i mean just you know think
of all things we learned and i'm sure
you know this you thought about i'm sure
yourself that all the things we learned
we had no evolutionary pressure to do
like running these this kind of podcast
and you know broken computerism and
talking about brains
it was incredible it just just cries out
that there's a universal method here
that's being applied to any anything
that
not to everything you know brains can't
learn everything but they can learn a
hell of a lot and it seems to be we
haven't really discovered the extent of
it yet
so this this says you know there's there
is this sort of
blank slatish
um
system if you want to call it that way
with these assumptions about our bodies
built into it
well the only thing about the the blank
slate thing is
it's such a dichotomy because i was
reading your book and it seems to be so
strongly determined by the embodiment
and the multi modality you know the way
that we're wired because you said
yourself that ai will actually evolve
towards you know robotics basically it's
not just the brain yeah it's it's how it
acts in the environment and how it gets
with those senses but i wanted to ask
one one final thing so
i went to a yoga retreat at the weekend
and after the physical components of the
practice were concluded matters of a
philosophical nature uh were
investigated and the basic case that the
yoga teacher was making is that we have
two selves right we have the emergent
social self and then we have the inner
self which i'm sure sam harris probably
might spoke to about you know the sense
of being and the sense of being is when
you kind of ignore the virtual social
program on the top and you know a
society it is an emergent virtual
program and it does many of the things
that the cortical columns are doing it
has the error correction it had you know
it's the externalization and
distribution so even though we're
programmed to care a lot about our
social selves um we are very stressed
when we lose control of our own
narrative because someone might be
saying something bad about us on twitter
so anyway this yoga teacher was saying
well there's something deeply fulfilling
um spiritually about just kind of um
going into your mind and and just just
that raw conscious experience but then i
felt like saying to him well you should
read jeff hawkins book because your mind
is just a load of prediction models and
all you're doing is traversing your
reference frames
so what do you what do you think i don't
i well i again asked me to talk about
things i'm not too familiar with but
i'll tell you i'll tell you a personal
experience i have okay i don't do
meditation and and sam didn't bring that
up but but i thought about it a bit i do
something equivalent to meditation um is
that when
i find things in the world stressful
um i just sort of shut out the world and
i think about interesting problems like
the future of humanity or the future of
intelligence what's the nature of life
and things like this and so now i'm
living in this world that is sort of um
is in some sense uh
pure right it's not it's not being
messed up with like i'm hungry or this
person's being nasty to me or
just like tuning it all out like oh my
god i'm not in trouble again
and then
so i think that's my own personal
meditation and i don't think i think
it's useful actually because uh i think
it helps when you when you think like
that you you're you're sometimes able to
get to deeper truths
um that you separate the body functions
and the day-to-day stuff and
and i often do my best thinking when
there are no distractions either on that
sometimes while i'm driving or sometimes
i'm just awake at night lying in bed
um
but where there's like i don't i don't
have to deal with anything else so
that's kind of like meditation and i
find i don't think it's useful i think
it's very useful because you it allows
the brain to sort of separate out from
the old brain stuff
and um and just have run a bit
sometimes it comes up some good ideas
you know
exactly i couldn't attest to that well
um jeff hawkins thank you so much for
joining us today it's been an absolute
honor
well it's been a pleasure you guys are
great i really i enjoy all your
questions you're really fun and i think
this is one of the one of the more
meaningful conversations i've had in a
long time i'm serious you know because
hey you know you know what you're
talking about
you know what i'm talking about you ask
great questions you're really deep
thinking about all this stuff so i think
that's wonderful thank you so much
appreciate that thank you so much all
right all right well i hope it helped it
was good for you guys
so that was a wrap
how was that guys
it's pretty great it's pretty great um
and honestly yeah i'm really pressed it
was really nice to talk to them it's
just
clearly you know you know it was like so
much more than was in the book
uh it building the book was really just
scratching the surface and uh i wish we
had like you know like just taking off
for a beer and like really dig into some
of the degrees
yeah what i i love uh i love people like
him because he's
so smart and and smart and a very um
he has such great common sense right so
when you when you ask him questions he
comes back with these
really informative answers that are very
uh concrete and you understand what he's
talking about so it's really fun to talk
to him i mean
a very very great learning experience
yeah i got the impression that
his research focus has changed a little
bit so when we were doing some
preparation for this we were looking a
lot into the htm algorithm which i
understand is now
um
they're pivoting away from that a little
bit so he was talking about some stuff
that they're doing with transformers
models and sparsity and quite a few
things i haven't heard about and also he
was really focused on um the particular
way of thinking about cognition using
these reference frames which he spoke
about in his book which i think is
actually a slight departure from from um
some of the stuff the mentor has had out
about five years ago
yeah but i definitely got the feeling
that he had like so much interesting
stuff
that's just not quite ready yet for
public consumption but um hopefully in
the book i often have this feeling like
ah the city just you know it feels like
there's more to this than there is in
the book maybe or maybe just needs more
time and i think i remember reading the
book it took like a year and a half to
write or so so maybe even right here you
know lots of things been happening
um so i do look forward to whatever he's
gonna publish in the future well what i
love too is you know he's more than
willing to admit look i've changed my
views you know i think yeah lots of
people run into are not able to do that
and if you agree with chalet's you know
measure of intelligence the mark of
intelligence is the ability to
assimilate new information
and to learn from it and most of the
people we talk to just want to stay
adamantly entrenched you know no look
this thing that i called xyz back you
know 30 years ago
you're wrong that it was limited to this
little area it actually encompasses
everything you know that that works now
like nobody ever wants to admit that
they've learned or changed or that
science has evolved
i want to push back on that a little bit
because there is something really
special i know we were joking that
science advances one funeral at a time
but there is something really special
about people who have an idea and they
see it through just like yan lacoon and
the deep learning pioneers everyone was
asking them why the hell are you doing
this in the 1990s and they and they hung
on and it was worth hanging on and it's
a similar thing with with some of the
approaches from nomento they've been at
this for such a long time now and there
is some really really kind of
biologically inspired and plausible
reasons why this might lead to something
interesting in the future but clearly
they've been at this for a long time and
and they've been sticking at it
well nothing nothing's wrong with
perseverance but perseverance without
adaptation is wrong
it's just perseverance when you're right
is right and prince raised when you're
wrong is bad
you're never 100 right and you're right
you're never 100. so that's the whole
point is you've got to be able to learn
you have to be able to well the learning
rate needs to be about 0.01
sure and the party centers 3 e minus 4 i
think is the correct learning rate
for all matters in life yeah all the
matters specifically
yeah and i agree like also i i'm really
glad i got to talk to jeff about
essential risk or something because of
course you know i take some songs pretty
seriously yeah it's a very common
experience to hear people dismiss and
extensively because they've heard the
bad versions of the arguments if there
are some
heroin encouragements of these arguments
that it's even from some very smart
people like yeah some smart people i
feel do the field a great justice than i
just can't feel bad they're against
um
and
it was really nice to see you know him
say like yeah you know what something
we're thinking about and
um
i i think honestly a lot of the
disagreement comes down to that yeah
like i agree with him and almost
everything really so they're not those
relationships
i was really impressed with with his
response and as you say you can see it
from so many different perspectives so
you can cover it from a grand
perspective talking about paper clips
and um
oh my god but
um i lost my train of thought yeah so he
i read the uh the less wrong article
which you linked to me was that steve
burns
yeah secrets yeah so
that was fascinating so so he was saying
that um
at the end of the day you've got a robot
rover on mars or something like that and
at some point you need to actually give
it something to do
and you might give it an instruction
and then
it might really want to complete that
instruction so it might predict that
you're about to give it another
instruction it says oh my god he's about
to give me another instruction i've not
done the first thing yet so i need to
kill him and that's not completely
beyond the realms of possibility now
i i agree with charlotte that i think
intelligence is externalized it is
embodied and there are many like natural
environmental limiting steps to
intelligence and you could talk about
all the replication stuff as hawkins did
but that's just a simple example i'm
just an intelligent agent on on mars and
i i need to have motivation because i
need to be told what to do what am i
doing am i building a base and then i
can
plausibly see how that could be um
you know misdirected
yeah i feel like it's
it the intelligence explosion arguments
i'll get mixed up with these like
motivational uh
concerns which i think is unfortunate
because they really aren't blocking all
like you could like these these concerns
about you know alignment and about
motivation will crop up whether you know
it takes 10 years or a thousand years
for ai to come to be at some point s
hawkins i think gonna pick so when we
put the work needs to be done
at some point you just have to build a
safety mechanism at some point you have
to write a motivation system so that's
why i think this you know kind of
research you know even if intelligence
blows it doesn't happen is still
something needs to get done
yeah and and
there is this thing um i mean you can
explain this better than me but
instrumental convergence which is the
idea that um you know many seemingly
innocuous goals incidentally lead to
dangerous motivations like
self-preservation and self-replication
and goal preservation and um i i can
sign on to that that seems very
plausible
yeah exactly i mean you give a perfect
example but like you know you give the
rover and the the the job will you know
build a thing but actually it's like oh
actually i wanted to build something
different
you know still was motivated but i went
to the first thing so unless we have
like some really sophisticated
you know system inside of it allows to
like you could equally value doing this
or do with another human
self-encourageability and which we don't
currently really love but implement
formally um
it's very likely that it will you know
having instrumental goals like keeping
itself alive so and where you're
stopping you from giving it your orders
like it maybe will damage its entirement
or something so you can't give it orders
or maybe if you if you're now if you try
to destroy the broker because this
malfunctioning maybe they'll retaliate
because if it's destroyed it can't build
habitat no can it so so yeah there's a
lot of ghouls like this also also like
delayed power seeking goals to sleep
obviously yeah if you don't know how to
achieve a goal and gaining your power is
probably like always a good move you
know getting more money more social
capital you know controlling for people
the driver resources like almost always
a good thing like almost no matter how
innocuous the goal might seem yeah but
see like on the other hand i don't care
if a rover on mars tries to retaliate it
has like no capability to retaliate on
us at all
and so the only kinds of like artificial
intelligence i worry about are ones that
are capable of expanding in some
capacity like they have to be able to
build things and they actually have to
be able to build
intelligent things so that's why i
brought up the point of you know if we
have a robot we're gonna need one that
can build you know
somehow or another replicas of other
robots to expand conduct more work
replace ones that were broken whatever
and it's not so infeasible to believe
that at some point in the next few
hundred years you know we'll have 3d
printing technology more than sufficient
to build silicon chips and you know
whatever else and as soon as you have a
system
that's self-replicating
and we don't live in a perfect world and
we have random variation right and they
have sets of instructions and also we're
going to need them to adapt to new
environments like it's going to be diff
difficult different building it on the
plains of mars versus
deep down in the valleys and mining
water or whatever so they're going to
have to have some capability to
allow variation you know then you have
the mixture for
evolution and once you have evolution
even if you had no goals like think of
it this way the ultimate
thing which has no motivations
whatsoever was inanimate matter and
that's what the earth was four billion
years ago and we wound up with animate
objects that have goals
so
despite philosophers and this is kind of
an interesting thing philosophers are
always like you can never get
ought from is but interestingly enough
ought arose from just stuff
right
yeah the very elegantly said
there's this weird kind of symmetry
breaking that happens somewhere i mean
in evolution the symmetry breaking
happened is because of physics because
things that don't want to replicate
don't replicate so we don't see them so
we found the first one from is comes
from just the fact that if there is a
possibility of replicator and the
possibility non-replicator eventually
you will only see replicators and that's
your first symmetry breaking
and corporate occurs that hopefully be
you know when we build intelligent
systems is that maybe we can break the
symmetry in a more you know in a less
dystopian you know
than a malthusian way and build systems
that aren't more motivated but i think
to be considered better than just for
your replication but it's very
non-obvious to me
you know how to do that safely it's hard
it's a hard trouble
but hawkins did say though that he was
more worried about the immediate threat
of um humans controlling the kind of ai
that we have now or
the kind of ai we have now being used
for bad purposes or or even things like
um the spread of false beliefs
that's
incredibly dangerous as well and that
that replicates like a virus that's why
that um you know that social dilemma
documentary like i thought this was a
very brilliant quote that was in there
and a lot of other people think it's
like not an interesting quote but to me
it was
beautiful when uh you know undermining
exactly he said we've always been
worried about when ai would overcome our
strengths
when we should have been worried about
when it would overcome our weaknesses
right and that and it's already you know
even though we don't have maybe we
forget if we have real intelligence or
not or whatever
clearly these
machine systems have overcome lots of
our weaknesses and they've created
things that are more addictive than
they've ever been found ways to
waste more of our time than now of
course there's offsetting things like
yeah we also get greater productivity
here etc etc but
we should be worried about when it
overcomes our weaknesses and what that's
doing to us and our children and you
know
one of my favorite examples is
it's called the food optimizer so this
comes from and yeah called roku and he
makes this example that so the way he
describes it is that in like the
19th century we collectively summoned a
weak super intelligence to feed all
humans i think the deal was kind of this
this capitalist you know market system
will produce really cheap food for us
but the system was optimizing a reward
signal based on profit of course let's
see how these things work so it's kind
of like a weak it's not sent huge it was
obviously not intelligent the weight you
know humans are but a weed is option
rising system it optimized for more and
more food and now we're at the point
that you know what 60 of adults in the
western world are obese something we are
literally eating ourselves to death and
this is a very very weak intelligence
quote and this is already powerful
enough in a way to you know get people
to basically kill themselves voluntarily
so imagine if you gave such a motivation
you know biggest you know food
corporation in the world you know build
their big their big agi you know using
hawkins you know thousand brandon
algorithm of course
uh and give you the motivation of you
know smith roth
yeah but this this gets to utility
and
similarly hawkins said oh you should
never clone yourself because you're not
cloning you're forking
i thought that was a bit of a
contradiction though because he was
talking about um
you know sending clones of yourself to
mars or seeding mars that's right and
that's the same thing isn't it you're
actually forking the human race when you
have a population of humans on on mars i
don't think um
who doesn't like forking what's wrong
with that well no but the thing is
because you we
we're doing it because we want to leave
a legacy you know i i like doing this
youtube channel because you know after
i'm dead people can
see who is that tim scarf guy but um but
you know you might say i'm going to
create a clone of myself because i want
to have a legacy but it's not a legacy
because after after the next day it
becomes a you know it's a different
person it's not connor anymore and
similarly when you were talking about um
you know why don't we restructure
society because
let's take away social media let's let's
fork and take away facebook and
everything else but what's your utility
function how could you how could you
justify that ourselves in that parallel
universe would be better off than we are
now well first of all i mean i think it
would be a legacy so you and i both
think that that the pixels on youtube
are going to be a legacy and those are a
pale pale shadow of a you know
projection of us right so
i would totally you know a clone of you
or a robot programmed with your mind
state or something that then can go off
and live its own life that's exactly
what a legacy is like that that is
a legacy it's not me it's a legacy
yeah like i
described to even more extreme crazy uh
versions of this kind of thing is like i
i fundamentally believe i'm like you
know a non-dual identity and like that
most of the kinds of identity is kind of
incoherent it's just it's just a
convenient abstraction in humans like
humans tend to be discreet that's just a
convenient property that humans have to
have happen to have there's no reason
that identity or minds in the sense have
to be discrete like this it just happens
to be the case that humans come in
packages it looks like they become in
you know one intelligence please one
unit of intelligence but there's
everything you should study
they have it they have a mark they have
to have a markov blanket exactly
exactly but there's no reason you can't
have systems that don't really there's
not like a clear separation between them
like the the only reason i think really
me and tim aren't the same person it's
because the bandwidth between our brains
is really low is interbreed it's lower
that it is intraprey like why is the
right heart for memory maybe that's the
person in the left hand also a different
person depending on your definition like
you know there's like split brain
patients where like the brain has to
actually disagree and like take
different actions and like fight with
each other so like really different
people i don't think so i think what
makes identity a synchronization in a
sense or like alignment so you see is
that identity the best way to define
identity is alignment with agua is that
like does the the system
coherently act without you know like
shooting itself from the foot so to
speak or like you know doing at all
so like that's why i think it's a really
great argument that for example ant
colonies for one animal that happens to
have like you know
very big individual parts because in a
way it is aligned you know not all the
parts were produced you have a
reproducing part you have you know
fighting for death eating parts or
whatever food getting parts or whatever
and they happen to not all be one body
that's just an implication detail you
were also just colonies of cells you
know it's it's just it's just
implementation details and matters is
the coherency with the synchronization
of you know knowledge and goals in life
yeah but again a lot of that is is
emergent
but you were saying as well that um
there's a kind of there's a there's an i
o bottleneck when we communicate and
this is um
a lot of people talk about neural link
in this context as well but i don't
think there is because when we
communicate
there's common knowledge that we both
have so it's a fairly efficient
communication mechanism and we're
invoking lots and lots of very complex
knowledge that we've reconciled so when
we read a book or when we
when we take on board information the
bottleneck is comprehension
i don't think it's the the bandwidth
sure as it depends on how like and by
bandwidth i also meant comprehension
back it's like if i could literally
i imagine we could you know take two
human brain would put them in the same
skull and could like to connect them
through some super cleopas closeum or
whatever and you know let the whole
thing synchronize and you're not diet
seizures immediately or whatever i think
there's an arsenal argument to be made
that is one entity
but you could also make an argument's
two connected entities and simply just
becomes continuous like a classic play
open when something seems confusing if
there's a discrete quantity evolved try
try continualizing the quantity and see
if the confusion disappears
very cool
well
gentlemen
it's been a pleasure
so see you next week folks
see you next week